all right and we are semi kind of live
what's going on I launch podcast
launchgaming.net and it is here it is
time to enter the star Field Long
awaited Impressions and uh this is a big
one this is a big one uh shout out to
Bethesda games obviously that provided
us the code to uh to actually cover this
and uh we're gonna start off with the
law it's gonna be very informal
introductions on my return from
hospitalization
so this is my first uh record but uh
let's start with my co-host Lloyd addict
super producer in the background how we
doing sir doing pretty good yeah we we
got a uh a pretty sizable amount of
content for you guys to uh over star fit
so I hope hope you guys enjoy it now
there are stipulations of we can't go
into some of the story aspects obviously
we don't want to spoil the game for you
guys anyway and I just want to get this
out of the way thank you Bethesda for
providing us with a code because I know
like legally we have to say that so
they end up getting all the dots you
know down in the t's crossed no doubt
and of course my brethren the sastra
Thomas Lord Sovereign how are we doing
sir good to see you brother I am good
that's very good to see you very good to
see you backing at it back at it again
unfortunately you know uh you have to
jump right back into the saddle so
quickly but um but just glad to see you
just looking energetic and back to
yourself so and excited to be here
because usually I can't be part of these
things because I usually don't have the
time to be able to you know play a game
in depth like this
um so I was fortunate to be off and
fortunate that we were blessed to be you
know with multiple coats so uh I think
this is cool because we're going to have
a lot of different perspectives on this
game which is I don't know a lot of
places are going to have that so very
true very happy to be here no doubt and
the new host of iron Lord clock
yeah like I was not needed it felt so
good I was like oh so proud I'm so proud
lord King David the host with the balls
good to see you brother thank you for
coming to see me and Sandy well wishes
I was I was definitely going there um
regardless to what I really didn't care
uh I I don't know there's just certain
things that you know that you have to do
so you make no excuses or whatever I had
planned for the day was that was not
even it wasn't even a factor you know
but I was getting up there and I'm glad
I did get there because
um I don't know I came in with super
positive energy that you will be leaving
within the weekend and when I got in
there she was just like yo me take this
stuff off of you and I'm like oh this is
dope and then we also we don't really
get a chance to to build because you're
in New Jersey so we got a chance to
actually build on some stuff and get
prepared for uh this week but kind of
sucks that you get home and then you
write back into this and then tomorrow
we and
I mean it's selfish that part of me is
selfish because it is I had to be under
control I had to be corporate King and
and and and run a show and don't go too
far off because there was nobody to be
like hey come in you know you know attic
you'd be like go go just go crazy it's
Sovereign
thing and I really had something like
set up for you know the PlayStation
bundle but
um
this is the first time I got a review
code and this was like huge for me
because when review calls do come up I
usually be like no I don't want to have
they just send that to the website let
those guys get what they're gonna get
and
you know this felt really special that I
was able to partake in it because you
know we're talking behind the scenes and
actually
this is the first game I hunkered down
in and was taking notes like on certain
things and it's I can't wait to to peel
back this onion because it is a huge
onion pulse I can't wait to peel it back
so thank you Bethesda for handing out
four codes which is kind of
um different normally you know people
only get like one or two or something
like that so I really appreciate the
fact that I was able to be involved in
this so no doubt and of course to round
out the ILP we have oh man Lords of
gaming dot Nets oh Nicholas Downey
individual I'm still gonna call you out
of dad I don't care
see you it's first of all senior editor
you know assistant chief uh
editor-in-chief the man wears so many
hats and it's definitely the lifeblood
of the site some of the best reviews
always always quality
yes yes yes and uh from a former
affiliate from other places that we
always work with together but it's good
to be able to do this with you how are
we doing Nicholas Downey uh we hanging
in there we hang in there I've been up
since 4 30 in the morning these
California storms have we're going crazy
so I I am tired but I am you know it was
uh 13 14 hour days at work and then
coming home and playing Star field and
sleeping for four hours and it's been
it's been a hell of a week but it's glad
to see you so flush with life and uh ILP
was definitely
um classic with King running yeah
uh I definitely enjoyed it and
definitely threw back to some of the
older um episodes you guys used to have
and I I love the energy
less professional episodes
professional so now I gotta give it up
to them I've been in the heat oh no I
don't mean King I just beat the
production oh the production
what was nuts is
everything got peeled back like you
didn't have the overlay we didn't have
all the other stuff and it was just us
it is as we are now so let's get to it
you know the audience said they're
impatient they don't want to hear about
you guys
[Laughter]
this is a game that has been in creation
for a long time with uh God Howard and
the team and Bethesda and obviously you
know this is this is this is the one
this is a huge XBox exclusive so I'm
gonna hand it over to uh Cole's addict
as far as setting us up and you know how
you want to approach it it's such so
many layers to this game so many
different ways we could start an
approach so I had to let you set this
thing up man
I have broke this up into small things
I'm scared of the static so I'm trying
to stay mute okay I broke this up into a
variety of uh things that we're going to
go over you know star field is
definitely you know that massive game
that we've been waiting for for a while
uh there are some things that I want to
be sure that we go over in particular
Express the character development you
know space combat something new for
Bethesda so I want to really focus on
that as well
and you know and I want to go over the
combat in general because I feel like
you know hand to hand you know guns it's
always been something different that
they've always used and I want to go
into that as well then obviously you
know we're going to Pivot you know this
is IOP we're we're notorious for
pivoting uh so you know first thing I
want to go over to is is the character
development I want to really break this
down because you know one thing that is
unique about iops we all come from
different backgrounds so I feel like we
can when we make a character we're gonna
make characters differently and you know
obviously we we got we got some uh you
know some some darker members that are
very particular on how some of the hair
is gone
so I I want because because
particularly with that I know that a lot
of characters and a lot of developers
don't do black hairstyles good or
anything so I want to really go into
that too because I want to I want to
make sure you guys were done right they
always
give them so um all right so let's let's
start with uh let's start with Keem you
know when you was making your character
did you could you make a king in
Starfield
my wife hates my character right because
she comes downstairs she goes oh that's
not it can you redo him and I'm like I'm
like 30 40 hours in uh uh I don't know
it's probably a customization on the
planet where I could work at it I was
sitting there I was trying to do certain
things
you're able to do a whole bunch of
things right and I didn't worry about
the enhancement part buddy what I was
worrying about is you know get in the
face right got it absolutely wrong and
um my God looks kind of crazy uh get the
build right but there were so many
different options and I was so eager to
just to jump in I really didn't care
what I made and I made the character but
it got close to what I wanted it was
just the level of customization
and I played a lot of Bethesda games and
you know they fall out everything
this game is just a little bit more when
it came to the characters it's
um current gen Bethesda you know what we
come to expect and I've I've become
desensitized to all the options that are
afforded to us because normally when you
go into a game this level of options
isn't there so I have to go back to
other games that are RPGs just to gauge
how far ahead this game is and I'm not
being or not taking uh for granted the
options right so I went back to a couple
of other games RPGs that actually let
you customize your character and I saw
how Limited in scope they were compared
to this game so that was my barometer
there so I was like okay so this game
really allows you to craft your
character in a unique way that you can
make the character your own in every
aspect of the character and I walked
away with it saying that the
customization is fine now my wife may
not like my character I was cool with it
after I finished and I said you know
what I do got to go back in and and
tweak them up maybe if I you know make
another character if I can't you know
fix them but um I heard that there's a
place on the planet that I can fix a
face or something like that and I'm
gonna go in and do that but no other
than that I mean to be honest with you I
just really wanted to get into the game
and when I was just like picking face
and it was like all these faces and then
I can work with the eyebrows and work
with the eyes and space them out and do
all the stuff
yeah it became a bit much and I was just
like let me get my guy you know it's
funny when you said fix fix your face
the only thing I could see is that part
in rush hour Chris Tucker and he throws
the thing on he's like fix your face
no it's and oh and it's the colors
shades
uh attic may have joked about it but
going in a lot of times companies don't
get skin tones right for uh darker
colors yeah see like your light black or
you're black black
we had we have melanin options
either you are this
or kind of looking like gold or
something in a bronze but
um now shout out to Bethesda I think
they have people on the team that were
cognizant and uh understanding that the
the black representation and just not
even the black the brown representation
the Latino representation the mixed
culture I saw a lot of mixed characters
that was there right so uh they took in
account of everything and and they
brought a fourth I I gotta get I gotta
take my hat off to him
yeah that's why I was saying like IOP
like we're a very diverse group and we
legit have different backgrounds yeah
for real
good job
um you know look
let's go with you man what what was your
opinions on this how did you go in there
thinking did did you get you a a car
going on there or are you looking are
you looking extra spicy and beefy
you know they had as much beef as far as
the build options from an athletic
standpoint that I could maximize you
know I thought it was cool you know
obviously you have the standard walk
animations you know how you can change
that pronouns were in the game so
they're very cognizant of everybody's
preference which I thought was really
cool
um I agree with King you know as far as
um skin tones complexions plushes like
all these different pigmentations of
skin and the way you can
um edit it I thought was pretty
interesting I almost like King I was
almost overwhelmed it was almost too
much at one point and I was like okay I
want to get to to my character but I do
want to shout them out on hairstyles I
did see a couple of hairstyles that I
was like okay we got some good
representation there and you know like I
usually go pretty simple you know
mustache gold and that's it you know
keep keep it light and clean I want to
give them credit though because this is
something I found out I know we'll talk
later is when playing the game
one of the mistakes I made was I'm
running around like an idiot with my
suit on all day like I'm running around
so I didn't have an appreciation for the
character I made because you know you
got that you got the helmet on whatever
whatever so there were some options that
I missed that said okay if you're in
settlements take your helmet off or take
your spacesuit off and then I got my
undersuit on and sometimes you can have
your little little cap or your beanie or
your boy head oh you've got any little
augments or whatever whatever it is you
got going on and I thought that really
immersed me and the last thing I will
say as far as character creation that I
thought was really cool is I was a
person that really started this game off
in fps and almost was playing FPS
exclusively
and when I went to that mold of third
person and I saw my character I almost
had to stay that way I almost y'all know
I'm a just one dude so I I didn't
anticipate me liking Starfield in that
way so I would say 25 oh the first 30 of
my playthrough was all FPS but once I
figured out those options it really made
me immersed into my character in the
world so I thought they did a selling
job about meeting nitpick is you know a
little open song with a little Bethesda
old stew hair texture energy
like if you gotta cry very stiff like
they still you can still see some
remnants of the creation engine and you
go yeah it's like the only move that you
see is what is when you switch to it the
boots like slightly just because yeah
yeah yeah exactly exactly so I got a
nitpick on nap part there but other than
that I thought overall it was uh
Improvement and a lot of good uh facial
animation for specific characters but
that was me
yeah so I think you know go ahead and
speak online real quick I will be real
with you guys I never care what I look
like I usually just hit the randomizer
like five or six times oh that looks
cool than just rock with that uh you
know expect the only time that I ever
like go into is like scars like I'm a
big thing like I want the scars to be
right you know I want the beard to be
right and the hair color everything else
I don't care most the time especially
like I always laugh when they let me do
it and stuff like demon souls and dark
so it's like dude I got armor on the
whole game I don't even you know I don't
I forgot I was an EXO in Destiny for
years it's just it's one of those things
I don't care I I don't but I know that's
really important to something like I've
seen Cog sit in like a character
customization screen for like two hours
before yeah so you know solve how much
do you care about this stuff do you care
or you just like it if you get it you
get it you don't you don't what's what's
on with you with Starfield
I don't two I always care because
I might have been exaggeration a little
bit yeah I mean but I I can seeking
people doing that right you try to get
into my new show what I like about this
character creator is is that you can do
you can go simple with it or you can go
more detail with it because what they do
is they give you General options like
when you know this this no size this
sort of knows uh sort of uh if there's a
Bend here there's a Bend there whatever
uh same for ear same for lips or
whatever they give you General sort of
uh archetypes right and then within that
archetype you can you can sort of move
things around and scale it to how you
really want so if you want that level of
detail is there if you don't it doesn't
force it upon you you can just kind of
be in a general sort of Direction when
you're trying to make yourself and
that's for me I always try to kind of
make myself so did I succeed no I did
not succeed I look like uh Puerto Rican
Chris Daughtry I think
so it's like Chris Daughtry with like a
little bit of color too it's good enough
you know what question like you know
obviously do you think you can make an
Hispanic person well on there or do you
think like just because you didn't care
if you took the time you think you could
do it better like did they represent
your people right that's what I want to
know
it's all about representation but I
think I think to what to Cox point you
still have a little bit of that old
creation and stuff where it's like well
the hair isn't going to be very Dynamic
it's not going to be very flowing you're
not gonna so even if if they try to
create a texture it doesn't look super
right
um it's better than before like when you
look at a Fallout 4 when you look at a
uh what you may call it a Skyrim it is
better
um but it's still not that where you can
really feel the texture and I'm running
I'm running on a pretty high-end machine
that doesn't improve it at all either
that is not giving me better textures
talk again but I will say this trouble
they are they are NPCs and there are
some uh there are some real story
oriented NPCs in the game that look very
good yeah I've seen African-American uh
NPCs that look very good someone uh like
look Jessica
there's a character that he basically
looks like this
like yo you did the vocabulous you got a
bag
room but yeah I I like I enjoyed it but
I was in there maybe 15 minutes to try
to get something in the realm of what I
look like and that was that I moved on I
spent more time on the traits than I did
on on the web yeah it took me a while
right yeah yeah and so I I did all that
all the physical stuff then I went into
the trades and I guess we'll talk about
the traits a little bit later so yeah
but the physical stuff I got an
approximation and I was okay with that I
don't know Nick what's going on bro what
character creation like how you feeling
what what was your journey like in
Starfield could you make us white people
in it listen listen here here's the
thing when you're the control C control
V and every Ubisoft game
um
I'm sure a lot of people didn't get that
that's why I had to say that that's good
but it's one of those things like I've
I've been making myself in games for
years like I am a stereotypical six foot
five 300 pound white dude with a beard
okay like it is plain and simple to make
myself you can throw a dart and find us
like yeah like honestly like like what
what addict was saying about hitting the
randomizer you hit the randomizer you're
gonna get me about three rolls in okay
[Applause]
but what I appreciate about that is that
it includes everybody everybody should
be representative in a character creator
because it's a role-playing game and how
are you supposed to get into a character
that you don't identify with so having
everybody be able to participate and
enjoy it and not have to spend the
entire game looking like a 2008 PS3 Xbox
360 white angry bald protagonist she's
fantastic
and I think what I liked about the
rollover from that is not only do you
have the character creator for that you
have the diversity of the people in
space as well all like you go through
any of these space stations there's such
a diverse group of people throughout the
space center it's like it's space you're
gonna see aliens you're gonna see you
know colored people are going to see
Hispanics you're going to see whites
you're going to see anything and all in
between and I feel like nobody was done
dirty or janky in the whole
representation I never looked at a
character model and went yeah that's
that's bad
um but yeah no I think character creator
was really in depth I really appreciate
how in depth it was I'm definitely not
one of those people that spends two
hours in the Character Creator like I
want to get into the game so it's like
maybe 10 minutes but like I said for me
it's like you know shave shave sides of
the hair Spike the hair up throw a beard
on it make it tall and kind of beefy
looking and call it a day
literally there's a chat no we have a
game how many times someone say beefy in
this podcast
now to be uh like we got to be clear
this is you're there are no humanoid
characters right everybody's as
human-esque you can have you know
different features exaggerated features
but maybe you know maybe somebody
assuming because it's a space game or
whatever you're gonna have like you know
you can create you know weird you know
alien species or whatever
everybody's a human-esque creature the
way it was described to me is like if
you compare this some like Mass Effect
this was took in place like right when
we started learning how to travel like
yes so we haven't really came across
anything you know crazy you know let's
let's move on to the backgrounds you
know there's over 20 traits in this game
and you know they they are crazy some of
these traits and what I want to ask you
guys is first off which Trace did you
pick
and I want to know if like those traits
impacted the gameplay in any way shape
or form doing anything in this game you
know let's let's start with solve
because I know you know the straights
you asked me a couple questions on those
trades
yeah so for me I went with the with the
general Ronin class right I was like I
don't want to be I don't want to be
beholden to anybody whatever but again
these things what they do is that they
give you initial traits right that you
sort of can build off of but you can
still deviate completely from them and
do something completely different so
with the Ronin class
um what I decided to do is like I'm the
type of player you will find out during
this thing during this podcast that I as
the moment you say go I'm gonna go do
what I feel like doing and and I for me
that is raping and pillaging uh planets
of their natural resources planets
planets yeah
of their natural resources and um and
stealing and unlocking whatever I could
get my hands inside
you can say it in conjunction with
pillaging you know what it means you
know I want to add on to this
obviously the people on the panel were
no stranger to like Bethesda style games
uh do you would you say this is the best
type of system they've had in terms of
you know making the type of character
that you walk around and do or do you
think that you know there's certain
things that they did better in other
Bethesda games
I think one of the things I always look
for immediately is if one of the traits
that I picked out
really comes to life when I'm playing
right and one particular one that I
picked was was heavy into stealth right
I wanted to see what the Stealth
gameplay was like and I went into it and
what was disappointing was once again I
didn't see any sort of uh specific
animations for stealth kills it's very
still janky you roll up behind somebody
you stab them and you have you have a
Thrust stab that you could do with the
with the you clicking in the right stick
and then you have just the regular
slashes and if you have a weapon that
has a specific sort of uh attribute
where it's like oh if you start if you
stab a lot it will speed up or something
like that or um certain uh like if you
hurt them x amount of times it'll it'll
like things will show a little bit
differently but there are no specific
kill animations for still so that that
bothered me a little bit now one thing I
did notice is with that stealth when you
when I equip certain things like there's
a helmet that I equipped and because of
my stealth attribute when I crouched
down
and don't move I blend in with the
environment the chameleon the chameleon
and then and then you get it to the
point like initially you can't move
right and then and you're you're
invisible and then you get it can get it
to the point where you just move slowly
and you're still mixing in and I'm like
oh my goodness I I blended in whatever
the environment was and I was like okay
this is what I want to see because a lot
of times in RPGs right
you'll have all these these stats and
these traits but the traits don't show
on the character right and it goes back
to what you said Cog I played the first
two days of this game in first person
when I jumped out the third because
Bethesda games you always know the third
person is always an afterthought like
nah it feels janky it feels kind of like
a mannequin I'm playing full-on third
person mode
you guys are crazy the only time I ever
went to third person if I was in a rough
[__] battle and I was like I gotta see
where these people are that's the only
time I there were some times where I was
facing like five or six ships I would go
into photo mode just to get get an idea
of where they're at like I'm going to a
photo mode I'll sit there okay this
dude's above me this dude's to the left
of me okay there's no one below me
that's where I'm going you'll love when
we get to the ship stuff
what I'm learning is not to interrupt is
that how attic play style is right
because it seems that me solving I'm
curious what king and Nick land is that
we seem to be more grounded in doing
because if you're more grounded and
you're doing stealthily stuff or you're
moving around you're going to appreciate
the third person character yeah
so so I can see and that's why it's so
much of what it gets to you that I want
to learn from because of how vast and
diverse this game is because I didn't
know about how the ship card but
continues talking yeah so quick question
because I didn't play this game stealth
I generally do go that way but I was
just like nah we going in there guns
blazing uh so I didn't play stuff how
was the AI function like because I've
seen a couple times with the AI wasn't
the best and sometimes they were okay
sometimes they were good and sometimes
they just didn't move how were they
going from the perspective of someone
trying to play the game in a stealth
manner so I'm playing on I played on
normal I didn't try to go any you know
difficult or anything like that put it
on normal
no and that's the thing I I kind of
again because of because of my play
style and me landing on every planet
that I can find and finding things I
probably shouldn't find early
um I got I got a pistol it has like a
150 power so I'm bodying everybody
it gives an automatic crit boom
boom no matter where on the body I hit
him it's a crit
yeah so in terms of approaching a
situation stealthily I have been able to
get infiltrate a place and have the
enemy not see me now unlike a game like
the last of us or something when your
companion character you sort of have to
suspend this belief and the companion
characters are obviously being seen by
the enemies but but the games yeah but
the enemies the enemies uh what should
we call the enemies don't see them right
so to kind of preserve that in here if
you're with a companion shout out to you
Vasco shout out to you Sarah yeah
they're gonna roll up and you're trying
to be stealthy that's out the window so
a lot of times I've been able to sneak
up possibly on like two or three NPCs
and again I got to drop on them I had a
Cutlass on one of them and I just hacked
them and one hit and I killed them but
again it was just disappointing there
was no specific animation to it but I
was able to do that so my impression is
that if you are by yourself and you tell
your companion character hey stay back
stay here
the whole story
you know what's funny
Mike and Patty was about to smoke just
as much as I was about to smoke yeah
like there was not one time where I told
someone to say
like nah I'm gonna be at the front lines
you gonna be right behind me sometimes I
just put that person out in the middle
of nowhere and be like you a giant
distraction right now you know you know
I want to add to the
playing the way we play
did your companion was against you or
for you because I to me don't go don't
go too fast you got to get these traits
out everybody gotta get these trades
too fast so when I say the companions
that I was with up until now which has
only been two one is the the robot Vasco
right and he um and he he's down for
whatever smoke he's down for whatever
smoke right and then and then I hung up
on the ship and I and I have Sarah the
member of constellation and she she is
about to smoke with factions that are
known to be uh outside the boundaries of
the law if it is if you're doing
something that is even remotely like
against the faction that kind of like
you know hey man they're cool like I
don't know why you're doing this she is
going to call it out immediately now
when when you roll up on pirates with
her yep she is about to smoke there was
a moment where I went into I'm on the
moon right now actually so it's right
now this is happening I'm on the moon
and I and I went into an interior
building the fight the pirates that were
in there and she he didn't come in so he
stayed outside I can hear her yelling
from outside oh you picked the wrong day
to mess with me and she has the shoddy
she has a shoddy so she's
murdering them and then when she's done
she comes in like yeah I'm done with
that outside I took care of that that's
the story you gave her no I think I had
a shoddy I employed I think if I employ
a certain gun she employs it so because
for whatever reason I didn't notice she
had a shoddy before when I when I
equipped the shoddy she all of a sudden
had a shoddy but I haven't manually
equipped any of them with any weapons
she doesn't equip weapons that you equip
because I could put on Equinox so I can
put on something else like that and she
won't put that on but I heard her beg me
for ammo and guns words oh wow yeah she
was like yo I need ammo and guns like uh
and I said okay hold on I looked at my
inventory I went and traded with her and
I gave her a couple of High Caliber like
Kraken weapons that I had that I wasn't
using in the solstice that I gave her
and and an omni and gave her the ammo
for it then I saw her switching in
between the guns
so nice
it there is some Jank when it comes to
the the characters like the the computer
controlled AI characters yeah there's
Jank there and it's just I I don't think
that we're at the point where AI for the
characters is there enough right we have
structurally we have uh visually we have
done all this stuff I think the AI on
the companions has hasn't evolved enough
in video games at this point for it to
be like they understand that you're in
stealth mode they understand that we're
not supposed to go and attack this right
now they're supposed to read the
situation we haven't gotten there yet
you're right you're right I just want to
push back and Shout out my man adoring
fan because he he he listen he his thing
is stealth and in the back right so he
played when I had Sarah
she would always blow up the spot if I
didn't as soon as you installed and you
see hidden and you see that that
indicated that you you know you're not
being wild cool I'm about to get the
drop and I'm pulling whatever suppressed
weapon I got and I was wondering why am
I not getting stealth kills counted so
what's happening is I'll pull out get
the first hit she coming
but a door and Finn as one of my traits
he plays all the way in the back and he
is always stealthily and he all about my
foolishness I just wanted to okay there
is slight behavioral it's very minute
we are not there we are not you all
right gaming is not at that point where
the companion AI especially with the
trading of the weapons and yeah I think
I think that's going to change going
forward and I think when with the modern
Community when they get a hold of this
they're gonna probably tweak that aspect
of it because
that's the only thing that like I saw
with this like now if you're finished
solve yeah yeah all right so my trades I
took boxes it didn't show up because I
don't I saw a box and I was like oh
right let's get that right I'm gonna be
running up on people and definitely no
no you're not
um
how I play absolutely no you're not and
second
um I took like that wanted thing because
you know people pop up like they'll send
agents at you the attitude
I wanted to be a space cowboy type of
thing and y'all run down I was getting
to the point where I've killed so many
of them I had bounty hunters showing up
it's like I ain't kill I ain't trying to
take you right now it's like and I was
like why he's like because I'm gonna
wait for your bounty to go higher and
then I'm gonna come for you so it got to
the point with if I saw them because
they would show up and help you in space
right but then afterwards they'd be like
yeah your Bounty ain't high enough for
me to care right now so after I found
that out I just started shooting them
too I was like no you ain't coming for
nothing you dying right here
I'm like waiting for that aspect uh the
arc tree
as far as how you pick is completely
different from uh other games in there
you know I mean it's probably along the
lines but it's different it was more
robust and then when you get into the
game and you see all the robust traits
that you act you could unlock and
different paths that you could go it's
gonna be supremely
um
individualized per person I believe
everybody here has had a different take
on the same exact game and that's
Monumental because we have five people
here and five people play Styles has to
be accounted for so going in mentally
physically you're going to see that uh
are you attached to certain characters
like I was attached to Sarah she wasn't
about anything that I was doing and then
it got to a point where I said to myself
let me win her over let me start doing
some nice stuff and I started doing some
nice stuff because it was at a point
where she was like she didn't want to
talk to me like get away from me I don't
have a conversation with you no you know
you're bothering me go away and then I
got to a point where I did enough good
favor in the world and she saw it and
she liked it and now she's talking to me
because I wanted to get to the Romantic
aspect of it you know I'm I'm trying to
get to the you know she looking kind of
cute so I'm like hey guys
we're in the lonely space nights now
that was going on girl like you're
hanging out you know what I'm saying
I got another character that's that's
named Bo and um no Sam Sam Sam Sam Cole
Sam cowboy hat yeah the cowboy hat do
with the dude like he's a wild dude like
if you want to go in the situation that
they put me in with this dude I'm like
man if you don't sit here just stay here
for a second because you acting up and
you you make them block hot so he's one
of those dude him and Vasco Bosco don't
care he he runs in rooms to start
punching uh pirates in the face and I
see the energy ball go down bicycles
like letting off like dudes just trying
to attack this ship Vasco wasn't having
any of it I was like oh I like you you
will stay at the ship
with you so I give him some stuff but
the AI needs some tweaking I'm not gonna
lie with the companions but maybe it's
my ignorance in assuming that the stay
here hold up button or picking a
different character to go with you
doesn't have a real relevance because
from hearing you guys it does have a
huge relevance and me holding on to
Sarah like is supposed to be the only
precious now I think I gotta let her go
and grab somebody else because I did
hire some crewmates and I gotta see
because I was that was my first thing
hire crewmates to see how they go in
aerial combat my thing is aerial combat
and when we get to that I can just
expound on it further but as far as the
trades and stuff go mine haven't
manifested themselves to the point that
it makes a difference in the game for me
at this point but on my skill tree my
skill tree now it Formed how I play my
game and I notice now that it's not just
normally like normally I wouldn't do
certain things but my skill set goes to
that weight and it makes that part
easier like it's lock picking now I got
options that'll pop up when with the
digi lock picking which is really not
lock picking and hacking it's a little
bit different lock picking I think I
hate that lock picking game I hate it so
much every time I succeed I get a vein
problem so I when once you upgrade the
the lock picking skill what happens is
it starts giving you uh indicators on
Blue which ones blue right it'll tell
you blue like hey and as you get more
and more proficient it gives you more
and more indicators you can make the
right choices and not when I learned how
bad I was at it I made my life's goal to
do anything that didn't involve lock
picking like
the good thing is they give you multiple
options to do something but lock picking
sometimes the easiest way they're like
you can go lock pick you can go through
this vent and you can do this get this
thing in in three minutes or you can go
around and do it in 30. well I guess I'm
shooting the place up like it's the
immersive Sim aspect of it that's still
like very present in these games it's
like okay just tackle it how you want
funny thing about the lock picking real
quick I I went in and I locked picked
this this Locker that was like expert
lock pick right it was experts I went in
right oh and they they have a sense of
humor these guys over at VTS oh I
wouldn't I said yeah I popped this I I
got it you know it was like because the
expert one is like 12 picks or something
like that is a lot so I go in
and it was literally literally
a piece of the chunko meat in there yes
wow I would have preferred they'd leave
me a little note like hi I would prefer
that they left me a note and said hey
maybe you shouldn't try to open
everything that you've seen in your song
if you get a chance in the lodge go
downstairs it's a a suit spacesuit down
there yes
I'm trying to get my master up so I can
get that suit Nick what's your
experience with Farmers like the you
know your traits and how did you how did
where did you go man how did you
formulate your character the uh my
problem is in these RPGs when you give
me a bunch of uh like options I
immediately become a war criminal
um
I picked the adoring fan trait because I
needed at least one person in the
universe
you'll tell me he not the funniest
tell your story like I'm a huge Oblivion
fan so it says they're like oh you have
a dooring fan I'm like I'm doing this
we're doing this and this dude literally
sat 30 meters behind me while I
committed the most violent
in the universe and then he's like oh
hey here's some ammo here's some friends
he's rewarding my bad behavior
um but like
well I love so much about this is like
the traits really played in like to your
play style but I loved how it was always
a positive and negative I love that
aspect because there's so much in like
Fallout uh three and four and Skyrim
where it was like oh there's all these
positive perks and you just had to pick
the positives you wanted but within with
Starfield you got your positive but you
got your negative it's like oh I want a
big baller house well you have a 50 000
credit mortgage you're like oh that's
not great
oh I can have parents but they take two
percent of all my earned income no I
don't want parents now never mind
that sounds like I gotta pay them to be
my parents
this is terrible like but like I love
that variety and like I am very much
like even in Fallout 4 I do not take
companions with me I do vile stuff by
myself
the office away Nick I do the stuff in
front of them and if they have if they
want if they want to pull up to me they
can pull up to me right then and there
there's no going back to the chip
there's none of that it's like it's
either you shut up or you leave or I
kill you there's no empathy oh my God I
already see how his playthrough oh my
God I I think the worst thing I did that
played off of my traits was I it's
Aquila I think uh I get to the store
first and the girl's like oh you
probably can't afford most of these but
have a look anyway so I bought the old
world 12 gauge shotgun yeah I bought 60
rounds of ammunition and that proceeded
to just go to town on that town because
I couldn't afford it
so that was obviously a save and then
reload because everything hit the wall
see Nick I wouldn't have reloaded I
would just left it I would have had that
bounty on my head when the whole no
galaxies come after you no no it's
pretty bad I'm not gonna lie I can't go
into any Galaxy without like six or
seven ships trying to shoot me down yeah
see
wanted a trait because I had that too
it's like oh when you're at low Health
you do more damage but bounty hunters
will come after you occasionally I was
like man in folate like three dudes roll
up with bolt action rifles who cares I I
get my first group of bounty hunters
it's 12 dudes and they Corner me in the
middle of a like an open field and
they're like hey you want to turn over
your stuff I'm like no I'm gonna fight
you guys I spent half an hour having to
Die Repeat Die Repeat
in a damn open Asteroid area with just
flat terrain and one rock so I had to
Ring Around the Rosie them with the rock
because I'm a Melee short-range
character saying they're reloading my
shotgun going can you guys leave me
alone
but like the all the positives negatives
um of the traits is really awesome
because I like having you know the
negatives to it that was one of the
things that made the outer worlds uh
yeah so special was is like you would
have all these pauses but you'd also
pick up negatives along the way and I'd
like how that's kind of baked in uh to
this I I really do agree with you guys
the um the AI at times could be um
a little bit challenging especially if
you like to play uh stealth especially
with our little robot friend I agree
with King that man is growing hands
asking questions later we buy a country
it's like even if he even senses that
you've been doing some smoke he's out
there well well the thing that would
kill me is I'm in like I'm in a pirate
spaceship I'm sitting there crouched
looting a locker
oh you hear him in the background saying
like oh you know my Firepower far
exceeds yours oh my God like there's one
time I was sitting there I was crouched
I was like I don't know I was fiddling
around with like a Foot Locker and
getting some food out of it and like
turn around I see this pirate go flying
by me Ragdoll because Bosco's just
hunched him through a doorway and I'm
like okay I guess we're fighting people
like it's it's all it's all good
um but I definitely think the biggest
thing I wanted to see see more improved
was the AI because it did feel very
Fallout 4-ish in terms of how the AI
interacted with the world around it yes
but I will say it was very nice to not
have my companions get stuck in doors or
yeah so I got some stuff
I got some stuff he just got that
everyone that had no issues please raise
your hand and King's like I can't raise
my hand
it's funny listen to everyone's play
Styles is so different and for me you
know I went space scoundrel because I
wanted to intimidate a little bit you
know with the talking I went persuasion
um I did regret not going more into
persuasive because there was like
certain situations where I just kept
following them I'm like look I'm gonna
shoot you anyway so I guess it doesn't
matter but I felt like I'd get more
money from them you just you just pop
some drugs
you could get nice yeah
I really appreciate that where
starfield's like hey you want to be more
persuasive go hit this little remember
in the outer worlds if you had a zero
intellect like you would just like to be
like dots for your response
listen persuasion is one of I'm so glad
I went to away but they did it in a very
cool way because there's so many
dialogue choices to try to convince
someone so it forces you to learn that
it goes real quick I I didn't persuade a
lot okay uh people they either wanted
smoke with me or I wasn't a sweet talker
I didn't have a golden top but I did see
the mini game a lot I failed it a lot so
like there were some that was green some
that was yellow some that was red is the
green one's like your likelihood of it
going through is that how it goes yeah
yeah a lot of it is the likelihood and
then it's basically it's like a turn
system so you have a set amount of turns
to try to convince the person to get
onto your side right now some are yellow
red risky that you could get let's say
to persuade some women cost six points
there might be one at the beginning that
it gives you if you choose it but give
you five points off the rep towards you
know you go over it or do you have to
match them like three here two here one
here or can you like have a three and
just hit a six and go straight over
automatically yeah
if you were to pick the right choice and
it's at High Point value yeah you can
kind of beeline but it's also based on
your skill level as well the other thing
I know is that I was failing a lot in
the beginning this game I have to give
but there's a lot of credit the amount
of dialogue if you scum save because you
like damn I messed it up so I'm a scum
I'm a scum save and then I'm gonna go
back I'm gonna pick the right choice
they write four or five different other
dialogue texts that are completely
different and it forces you to learn the
mindset of the person you're trying to
convince so the amount of dialogue in
written language that they have for the
persuasion system is amazing I will
highly advise if any people like
persuasion and manipulating people go
highlights
I think the blessing yeah the biggest
thing I didn't like about the persuasive
system there was some in there but I
wanted more of what you picked at the
beginning the traits to go into that
that dialogue it does it does they think
that like I guess I came from like
Baldur's Gate like every other dialogue
had stuff like that so if I had like any
kind of medical situation where I was a
cleric like it automatically he's like
you a cleric you can have this dialogue
no bro they got that but no but I just
didn't see it a lot in my playthrough
but keep in mind I'm shooting a lot of
people I wouldn't yeah you killing it
murder and pillaging and doing what you
was doing in space for me I would have
options medical space scoundrel and
persuasion some of them based on what I
was doing was a direct win because of
how my character was manifested others
was kind of like okay you got to do the
persuade you gotta you know win this
person over but because my stuff is up
but back when I was saying with ryujin
that that that faction line that I went
through you know it really if you like
that place that well if you can hone it
and you can hone it well and you can do
manipulation and get people to move and
do things out of spots and it is insane
like it the thing I will say is this at
first my my only point of contention
when we uh but I'm curious how Nick
feels about this because I don't know if
this is new to be that's the games or
something that I missed or not but they
had a part where you know you get your
skill and then they have the challenge
well if you do turn the speech checks or
you kill 10 ships then you'll get this
so I'm like I hate where's it at I did
that but no they really want you to use
another skill point to now invest in
that challenge and that upgrade that's
the biggest thing I didn't like right
and that's the that's the controversy
and I'm curious with Nick on that how
did you feel that and I'm gonna get back
to the rest of my character build but I
was curious how you felt about the the
up when you pick a skill they have
challenges to make the skill like four
levels better yep right but if you pay
ticket you have to if you get another
skill plug remember skill points take a
while to get now especially if you're
not addict and you're not destroying the
Galaxy
37. like so for others it's a it's
harder to get a skill point so every bit
of investment counts how did you how did
you feel about that system and how did
you use that if not I'll tell you about
the rest about my trades see I I like
that system because it really makes you
hone in on a character because I think
my biggest criticism of Fallout 4 was
you could be everything yes if you
played that to Max Level you could max
out every every skill tree you had and
you could just be this superhuman that
could talk gun and blast your way out of
everything what Starfield really makes
you do is go okay what's your specific
Place how do you want to play because
it's like you know my thing was shotguns
and knives so I picked up an equinox I'm
like ah it's just a laser gun I can use
this thing my God it was like watching a
toddler with a bold action World War II
right it was terrible terrible like but
then really make
if you're going to
build you two I'm not going to say Force
that's kind of like a strong word but
they definitely make you focus in on
what you want to do and what you want to
do best I think I strongly encourage you
yeah to continue down continue that I
didn't yeah I didn't mind it but I do
prefer the old Fallout Skyrim where like
you get numbers to go into individual
skill points like I prefer that because
I feel like I have more control over
what I want to do like when you have
dialogue checks and like Fallout four
not Fallout four but Fallout 3 it would
be like your speech is 38 out of 70 or
28 like you can still do it but you have
for the the skill check that they want
you might not succeed like I prefer that
system but not there you can see it if
you're paying attention to it because I
do persuade a lot so it it gives you the
option to hey you it has the green next
to it a plus two or plus three and as it
goes down it gets into the red now you
might be able to bully your way through
it if you pick an option and they also
have the um if you if you do it right
enough you can press the x button to
Auto persuade right right so they give
you a lot of options in that persuade if
you're gonna go down it and then like
like y'all was saying the more you
persuade if that is in your skill set
and you unlock that extra perk in there
you can choose to use your skill point
on that persuade to get the second tier
and then get down to the third tip I
like this format better than the
previous formats before because like you
know like Nick was saying
you become a God and in this game you're
not going to become a god of everything
you are going to become a god of
something particular like you're going
to become a space real Barren right or
you're going to become like a stealth
God or or persuasion King whatever it is
but you're not going to be able to
master all of that all of them well you
can't yeah
yeah it's different in that from the
onset in a Fallout you could do that
right you could just go I'ma pick one
here one here one here one there and
each of those is going to give you
enough to be able to see all those
options and be successful when you
couple that with you know you know
drinking a potion or something like that
to get that that particular skill up
right here it encourages you to do that
and it simplifies it so I I could see
somebody who's a big Fallout fan come in
and be like oh they overly simplified
this and I think
I think it would be a valid criticism
but I do like the fact to Nick's point
that it it kind of
when you come in when you finish this
game my feeling is that you're going to
have a character that you identify with
specifically for what they were able to
accomplish within this world whatever
whatever sort of specialty they have
um and I think that's much different and
again it was I think it's a risk on
their part but I think it's them being
confident in what they've built that
they're like nah we don't you don't
necessarily have to be a jack of all
trades master of none if you focus down
on something and like we talked about
you focus down on something from the
very onset you could see that stuff
reflected in your character in a way
that was harder to see in an oblivion or
a Fallout or a Skyrim so it from the
onset they tell you that you feel like
these perks are meaningful are
meaningful so I I like it I can see you
know somebody else coming in but like I
used to have more choice and
I don't know sometimes they made they
made some decisions here that I I'm glad
that they made in terms of that we got
to get the attic because for me like his
playstyle seems so just murder
everything right so I'm it's dying to
know like I want to hear how he did it
what she was doing out there what was
the what was this
I picked everything that let me live
longer
if my health went certain my I got more
HP I picked one that said I had more
oxygen at HP I think it was like space
something I picked DNA did it okay
I picked everything that let me be in
the Smoke as long as possible
and then I started like you know going
up on medical making sure my guns were
right you know upgrading consistent
amount I remember there's a time where I
had a conversation I went into into this
room and this chick was sitting there
and she was like I had to get something
from her and she wasn't and I failed the
persuasive and then I talked to her
she's like I've already told you I don't
want to talk anymore and I talked to her
again and she said the same line and I
was like I'm gonna give you one more
chance
and I talk to her again she said
something else and I and I turned around
I walked back for like five or six
seconds
and then I turned her I was like you
know what nah
I always start to smoke with the biggest
dude in the room okay because they don't
see it kind of big enough
so I'm sitting there I I have so what I
have is I have I got an electric gun uh
for for robots I have an explosive
shotgun I have a I have a a handgun that
shoots three bullets
I have a like like kind of a Scout rifle
from Destiny that catches people on fire
oh damn and then and then I just got
grenades for days grenades for days and
I got a bunch of medical stuff and I I
kid you not like every conversation I
don't there ain't no need for me to
reload that safe because you it's not
that I'm trying to talk to this
persuasive to save me I'm trying to
persuade you to save you
and so that I don't have to kill you and
you know sometimes I win most of the
time my dog will be worth you got like a
zero and persuasive pretty much uh
there'll be a couple couple times where
you know the persuasive work you know
Sarah
I keep her at the lodge okay she don't
see half the stuff
as far as like as far as like companions
go I don't like I did run into this
individual on the ship on a ship that
her ship was broke down and you could
tell like uh when I talked to her like
the little the little stats came up
and the way she was talking she about to
smoke too but I didn't have what she
needed to fix the ship so I was like you
know what I'll come back later I got you
I'll come back later well I forgot where
she was and they don't really give you
any kind she's still in my game she's
still floating in space somewhere like
so and I look for it too I look forward
to man I look for it so real quick
because I want to before you pass it up
the king I wanted to ask you in
reference to because you're so
space combat as far as you know ship to
ship Carmen I think King also played
that way too but like one of the
struggles I had was trying to get into
that interface and and learn it because
I thought it was an exciting way to play
versus traditional Bethesda explore what
I would consider what probably me and
solve and you know maybe on foot
because uh you know you just because
what I want to do because we pretty much
like butcher like the character
development I don't think we really got
to go too much into that yeah you want
to just go and go straight into combat
yeah we can do combat yeah so because
I'm curious I want to start with you
because you clearly the most competitive
Lord
with King with King because we talked
offline so I want you two up next to set
us off because I didn't play that way
until very late and then I started to
understand wow did not you know how
Dynamic it could be but I didn't know I
wasn't equipped because I didn't go that
way with my best character so
so how did that whole start for you you
were just running down on people how you
was doing it so right now you know we're
going to go over uh you know ground
combat guns weapons and the combat in
space I
like I said we pretty much went over a
lot of the ground stuff you know I I
stuck to close range weapons and won
long range weapon and something to
disable robots with that's generally how
I fought now I did say you know Bethesda
is known for their combat they've been
known for years you know from Vats to
the Fallout and how they handle
hand-to-hand combat Elder Scrolls the
one I asked you guys real quick when it
comes to this you know we don't have to
go to this In Too Deep
um how is this combat different from
what you expect and is there anything
that you could have wanted for it to be
more improved now we don't have to talk
about frame rate obviously who people
playing on Xbox frame rate could have
been make the combat better but you know
what was what stood out in the combat to
you guys
um I thought I would be fisticuffs right
I thought it was gonna be a fisticuff
dude you know take the box so I'm gonna
run up on you and that quickly learn
back off me boy like like my My Bullets
is Hot For Real so I'm like all right
cool I got a shotgun very early on and
it was it was a golden shotgun I was
like okay let me let me rock with this
legendary shotgun and two shot blam you
done two shot playing so my shotgun
proficiency went up without me even
knowing what I was doing okay so I was
like oh okay let me let me just add
everything to my shotgun so my shotgun
is pretty much close to max out it
didn't get to level uh three yet because
of the tear system
but I got to level two then I went down
to ballistics but I also noticed that I
was going to go into space engagement
let's go so
I wanted Vats
and I understand why they didn't do it
yeah right part of me does wish they
would have had like a certain astronaut
suit that let you have Vats for that one
suit that's right somewhere yeah give me
give me the Iron Man armor from Earth
that would have been cool but you
obviously for IP copyright purposes you
could put Iron Man yeah
yeah right then it can change right you
put armors in space get the vibranium
suit you should go mining vibranium um
because it did come from outer space
anyway
um back to what I was saying it's just
like all right so I I did all of this
stuff and I got my proficiency up this
way and I started getting weapons and I
noticed I said you know what I'm a stick
away from the energy weapons and I'm
gonna stick to the ballistics because my
ballistics started going up because I
put I picked ballistics on my shootings
and stuff so like this this game
if you're proficient in an area and the
game is like kind of guiding you into a
way you're going to start allocating
your perks your your levels your skill
points to those perks that can make you
more efficient in the world so really
right now when I'm doing combat I stop
worrying more or so about Vats and I was
able to use different pistols and stuff
and I thought the aiming was a whole lot
better than it was the Bethesda games I
thought the inside combat was a whole
lot better than Skyrim and stuff like
that because you know using the sword I
didn't really use it too much thing it's
it's kind of weird but here
it felt a little bit more connected you
felt a little bit more there and I must
shout out little man because little man
is a is
night and day when you're playing on the
series X in a series s the series s
he's stable he's running around he's
fine he's no problem I think the the
extra uh resolution on the series X
tends to bog down in certain spots where
you have more people on the screen and
it's going to say like new Atlantis with
the with the dancing of all the NPCs
right but little man little man is like
what's up like where are we going what
are we trying to do and I don't have any
problems with little man so I was really
happy there now the space I'm a wing
Commander guy let's go and it was like
what was that game charvis something
like that that came out was like space
chorus chorus chorus of course the space
combat and that was pretty fun
and I was like please I want to know how
they're going to do it because I'm gonna
be in space more than I'm gonna be on
land that's that was that was my whole
mindset going in I'm going to be a
pirate and I'm going to steal ships I
got to the point now I have seven or no
I have eight ships now all stolen
unregistered except for the one ship
that I do have because it costs a lot of
registered ships but you actually make
money because there's always like four
or five thousand dollar difference
between registering and selling for the
most part so I've literally just been
like robbing people in space taking
aback registering and selling it and
making like are you ready first you have
to steal the ship you got to steal you
have to take it back I haven't stole my
solve him you stole him your friendship
oh yeah I saw mine real quick I don't
want to take Kingston but uh so I went
to a settlement and they were like hey
one of our settlers got caught in the
storm can you go help them I was like I
said please
so I walked out and I said oh that's a
pretty ship let me go grab this real
quick and I'll come back and help them
so I I went stole their ship took it up
into the atmosphere so it recognized it
as I stole their ship I haven't shipped
now I landed again to try to help them
they're like nah we're good
all right
one quick addict one quick because it's
I had one opportunity because I haven't
did a lot of space
and I'm running around was addict told
me about the scanner right well in the
new thing hit the scanner and then you
can see it talking hell I didn't know
about that Anatomy I was running around
like a fool we got to bring that up real
quick like Bethesda there needs to be
more information prompts on this game
there's so many people that are just
confused on what to do to do because
it's just a simple tutorial on the first
time you board a ship they do it but
it's just like they just tell you like
one scenario that you use that oh yeah
you do everything else but we're not
gonna tell you that this is the only
game that has the most layers to it that
they said man go figure it out
to way too hardcore but that's the where
they're trusting that you know that
there's so many complexities to the
system I haven't
made anything and they haven't told me
how to do any of it
I go to people stations stations and
when I'm in there I have the materials I
do all these projects but nobody told me
to nope nobody see I think this is part
of this is Starfield here you go
go figure it out now I will say I will
say it go figure it out it's still there
not holding your hand but it is more
streamlined than like when you go in
like Fallout 4 Fallout 4 was like all
right all this crap all this junk that
you that you got yeah you can put it
like you can build the gun from scrap
right car you can't really do that here
in this game here you can modify this
that the other right so that was even
more intricate and if you didn't know
what you were doing you were like oh
wait a minute I can get this and this
and put this thing on here here it's
simplified and that you go you find the
the pharmaceutical lab or you find the
the helmet enhancer and you just go in
and if you have the material if you have
it it'll light up
they didn't have the materials because
attic is not collecting materials
so much material from all the ship
destroying I do you have no I I have so
much solve of how to sell it
when you destroy a shot do you is it
automatically go into your hole Yeah
think that some of the ship parts you
have to collect questions
let me finish okay
I I just want to before you just got one
tangent now I don't want to forget
because I'm the only person that has not
one ship it seems like everybody else
got a ship except me so I said I went on
a mission looking to steal or get
somebody shipped right uh try to get
somebody on the planet because King told
me oh look in the air if when they
landed go get it yeah
let me get these balls okay I had to get
Sam Cooke I had Sam Cole with me he he
saw me I closed I said Sam wait outside
right I'm going to go talk to the
captain close the door he's like yeah I
just landed my ship you know I just had
a little problem I said you need any
help so he was like no no I got this on
my own close the door pull out this
pressure oh I don't know Sam Cole was
disliked it oh I'm I'm never running
with you or something like that can't
use this [__] because I like Samco
that's my man the only other opportunity
I had to rob somebody and this is what I
know I'm too good a person I was in a
Zone where a lady full grandma said hey
hey there I I held it hey how you doing
she was like Hey I'm doing it you better
come over I got some nice meals some
nice treats so I was like all right so
it's gonna be dark I'm docked up for you
food she had a spread with food nice old
woman some Hansel and gretels so I said
well I said what's she like that beefy
body
I said what's the catch she's like no
you know I'm I'm a you know sick woman
I'm I'm a widow my my husband died I was
like you running out of his space all
along she had a big attic she had a
b-class ship well but you wouldn't be
able to drive it so I was like unless
you be class yeah yeah but I was close
to bigger I could have a lot but but the
thing is is I think that particular
thing they let you take it because she
can give it to you in a mission or
something like that so I did I couldn't
do it I could
this is when I figured it out I'm on a
planet and my son is sitting there he's
like Daddy did you see them laying over
there so I'm like oh okay so I put on
the backpack where I got unlimited run
because it gives me oxygen so I'm
running and I'm jumping and zero gravity
is there so I'm flying all the way over
there to him I get to them and they was
like yo we need some water yeah yeah
yeah I'm like oh man yeah I'll give you
some water so I went over to the ship
when I checked it out I was like oh I
can do this this is it's about my speed
yeah
you you strolling through inventory oh I
can do this it's good oh so you so okay
so see and this is this is where I love
this game that's where the game is for I
ain't going for it continue the the
level of piracy
that you get to do like I go through the
hole
and I and I'm I'm in I'm in dog fights I
learned in dogfights never have your
speed full yes thank you bro I would
make thank you yeah
have it down down 23 and you're able to
turn yeah just turn and they get behind
you and they just stay behind you
there's actually like I keep my Speed
Max because most of the time I'm
fighting five or six people what you do
is like when you're going up you
decelerate and you'll go sideways
whoa what what I do is I I stay at
probably at 20 miles an hour okay and I
kill everybody
get them head on as they turn follow
behind them shoot them take them down I
go after the lowest one to the highest
and I have my repairs on me so I'm doing
repairs while I'm shooting but also my
engine mates that are there I got people
that's highly proficient in shielding
ballistics right so and pilot so I went
and that's where I I focused on I
focused on getting my crew together that
was going to do that and I did that at
Coruscant but the thing is
what y'all don't realize is if y'all
fight near a planet and you down the
ship there's a crash site on that planet
yes
so you go down to the planet you scan
the planet after you got all that stuff
out of space you scan the planet and
then you go down to the crash site when
you go down to the crash site you're
getting more materials
actual [__] you know how many ships I
put on planets oh I just look I just
realized how much money I've just left
yeah you left you left tons of tons of
stuff I I really got one time I was on
the free free whatever they're called
free um man that faction the Free People
freelance I killed everyone in their
orbit like you know how much money you
got left on the planet that went down
but what what what I've learned now
you can I've unlocked the perk where I
can Target them and I Target them now
and I Target just the engines
once you disable the engines you can now
board the ships so what you want to do
is
you want to disable them to the point
where they're bro the the engines is
broken but they're not destroyed then
you're bored you kill everybody on board
you take the whole then you can take the
ship
take the ship fix the ship and it's part
of your your ship line right now right
so now what I've done is I I stopped
destroying the ships because there's no
value in destroying the ships there's
value in taking down the engines
breaking the shields down taking down
the engines boarding the ship stealing
everything off the ship from the
passengers to the hole and taking the
ship fix the ship then sell the ship so
I didn't get to the point where I'm I'm
close to the point where I got enough
money so I could take a couple of ships
sell them and then get that bread like
because you got to register them
register them sell them then get the
bread back and then uh conveniently
cycle it but the the pirating aspect the
ship stuff
it's Way Beyond Wing Commander I was
hoping for it to just be right there be
close to 3do's Wing commander and it has
far exceeded it I the the space aspect
of this game alone and I can see where
Todd and the team was really uh excited
about it because for what you did on
Fallout on Earth that's cool and and now
you can go to different planets and it's
kind of the same and you're just trying
to figure that part out so you're really
doing story here this is the whole new
aspect that they've conquered and he's
done it in such a way that it is is and
I'm still evolving in this space I'm
still learning in this space because I
wasn't able to take b-class ships and I
just got that and I was like okay let me
see now I got an Achilles ship I I stole
an Achilles ship and those Achilles
warships is is probably one of the most
versatile when it comes to fighting when
because when you like attic was saying
when you slow down and you accelerate
behind them you do like a 360 turn and
then you position yourself right behind
the ship and then you hit the lock on
button hit the lock on button and then
you can Target either Shields engines
which one I need that skill what skill
is that well that you got to go to the
technical part where it's everything is
space based
right so it'll let you pick what thing
to Target yes okay because you notice
when you're fighting in space you have
to press next you have to Target and
then press X and it'll bring up your
skill yeah yeah now time will slow down
a little bit but not a lot they can get
out of your age okay right so what what
also you can do is when you start
building up these perks you can heal
your ship while you're fighting yes with
the hole with the right but if you look
at the bottom you have points that you
can like if they take some shielding
yeah
that's the added layer to the space
combat that Wing commander and stuff
didn't have yes right and and I think
they make up for certain things like
they they don't have now but I probably
didn't unlock that yet so I'm probably
talking out of turn but this aspect of
it the space aspect this is where
Starfield shines the most to me you know
story is great we already know what that
is going to do a story we already know
what they're gonna do on Earth you know
minus the vat system we already knew
what that combat is like we were more
skeptical about this combat than if they
was going to get this combat down pat
and I think they far exceeded my
expectations when it came to it you know
now solve I won't get to you because um
obviously I don't know how much space
fairing you did but it's seems just
styled may have been a mix between mine
and theirs but curious how your combat
overall was well to start out like so
ground combat so ground combat like I
talked about before I was initially
focused on stealth I said let me see how
I could play this game really stealsely
and use melee weapons right and I
quickly realized that it I just wasn't
gonna have fun with it like I said like
with melee you have you basically have
your right trigger which is allowing you
to swing right Swing Your Weapon you
also can click in your right stick for a
lunge attack right and then left trigger
is a block right so you have that but
apart from that like I was I was kind of
disappointed that you didn't I didn't
see any sort of real animations for
stealth kills anything like that so it
really it did not feel like I was gonna
have fun playing that way so to to
King's Point I immediately switched to
ballistics right and I switched to I
switched to human-esque ballistic
weapons instead of laser weapons and
stuff like that the laser weapons are
cool but I I just felt that the oomph
and the impact of the ballistic weapons
was very cool so like I was saying I
play it I played it in third person mode
and I go into combat scenarios and the
thing that felt good about it first off
again and this is a caveat that I have
to say because I again I don't know how
the performance was on the console side
but on the PC side you know I'm able to
enable g-sync and all that stuff I don't
know if you're able to enable the vrr on
your specific TVs in conjunction with
that with the Xbox and stuff like that
but I was able to do it on the PC and
when I connected the PC to the TV as
well enabling vrr smoothed out that
experience considerably so that
smoothing coupled with the fact that I
do think that the the combat uh is much
much better than than what we've seen in
their previous games right Fallout 4 was
a decent jump over Fallout 3 right uh
you still had bats if you needed it I
think here it's almost I'm saying we
don't need Vats we don't need bats
although I would have liked to have seen
it because I want this man I want I want
the Cinematic nature of bats right well
I was like I'm gonna blow your head off
I'm gonna do this and so far I haven't
seen that in this in this game so that
that is a little bit disappointing but I
will say that the that the gun play
feels a lot better I don't feel like I'm
shooting off into into space
um I love the fact that wherever you are
whatever Planet you're on how your
combat situations are going to scenarios
are going to play out is very much
dependent on the gravity of of the
planet right like if you I I right now
I'm stuck I'm in like a combat scenario
on the moon and obviously every little
jump that I do I'm flying up into the
air and then I hit my Boost pack which I
finally unlocked I locked my boots back
and I'm just soaring across the
landscape so all of a sudden now I have
The High Ground on all of these Pirates
and I'm just popping them boom boom boom
boom so that adds another layer to it
but again it wouldn't work if the gun
play did not feel that much better again
and
like I said I have the the g-sync and
all that stuff I know helps it but um
yeah I didn't feel at all like I was
like man I'm fighting against these
controls these weapons are missing for
no reason everything that you that I've
equipped in terms of perks and upgrades
to these weapons immediately show uh
give give me uh some sort of feedback on
the weapon that that improves it for me
so I'm very happy with it so far I wish
the AI was smarter
um
I would say I was smarter because they
do sort of you have ai that stands back
and tries to sort of snipe at you you
have ai that sort of mid-range sort of
tries to shoot at you and then you have
ai that guys that'll bum rush you with
oh they got to run down Cutters with the
Cutters they got with the Cutters with
the melee weapon and those guys uh like
again I got the shotgun that's going to
drop them in one or two shots and the
pistol is definitely gonna drop them in
one shot so um so I do wish it was
smarter but maybe that's me not going up
to a higher difficulty level but but
that but overall I enjoy it and I don't
feel like I'm fighting the controls now
jump into space could uh combat apology
I'm curious I haven't done any actual
combat except from except for the
simulator stuff to to get your license
to go because I I jumped in and I went
with the Vanguard right you know over
new Atlantis I signed up with the
Vanguard and part of joining the
Vanguard is hey you got to show us so
you can defend yourself in a ship so
they put you in a simulator and so I did
I just realized there's a license for
[__]
because the Vanguard is uh basically the
volunteer military Corps for for the
United comedies right so I went and I
said let me go do you know me I'm trying
to be nice and they're trying to do the
right thing even though like I want to
have all of these uh Protections in
place even though I'm committing heinous
axles
so I went I did that so that's that's
the combat I've gotten into so what I
what I will say and to King's Point I
agree completely
is the fact that I when I saw all those
different gauges I'm like oh man I don't
know if I'm gonna be able wrong at first
me wrong right and one of the especially
because I forgot that I can go out into
third person mode because when I go out
into third person mode now I'm like
because I I'm I agree with y'all I love
I love wing Commander I love Colony Wars
um but I'm at a point in my life I don't
want to do I don't deal with those
gauges or whatever I want to be I want
it to be more of an arcady experience so
but what I realized is that they really
have found that perfect mix with it
where it's like hey you have to pay
attention to the gauges on your ship
because it's going to tell you like you
said hey I gotta there was an instance
where I had to sneak into a certain area
right because uh oh yeah yeah the
religious zealots
yo you need to go get this info but you
cannot make any noise so it tells you
and I didn't realize that hey shut down
your engine completely
quietly in yeah go collect what you
gotta go and then and then do a a jump
real quick and get out of there I was
like oh my God I can't believe so the
thing is that level of death
by the way just just
I looked at them I was like I'm not
gonna engage in this combat right now
let me just follow the story so I did
that
um but what it made me realize is that
there's depth there that is they've
managed to streamline it in a way where
it's not overwhelming it still feels
somewhat arcadey especially when you're
playing it in third person mode you see
the lasers fly back and forth you see
the the dog fighting and it feels it
feels really good and it feels like they
put a lot of time and effort into making
it feel like something that isn't like a
simulator like a flight Sim where it is
hey if I don't pay attention to this all
this stuff properly I'm gonna lose you
can still sort of hey
I'm going to dog fight this guy and
chase him and try to you know and try to
lock my missiles onto him and blow him
out of the sky and it still feels fun in
an arcady way but it also allows you to
sort of hey I need to take power away
from this particular thing to put more
into missiles so I have extra missiles
to shoot and I to me it's robust but at
the same time it works for somebody
who's not doesn't want to get into the
minutia of that that sort of stuff and I
I think I'm gonna enjoy it I haven't
done a whole lot of it like I said I
only did that simulation and I haven't
I've avoided it in actual space so um
but yeah I what I've seen I like so no
that's cool I'll jump real quick because
I got to give up experience is that the
way I was playing it initially
as a Bethesda but they were having
kicking his way
looking at the questions okay yeah it's
just like I'm playing like a Bethesda
ass but that's a game I'm just gonna
beat you my play style is I'm going into
the room I'm breaching clear I'm gonna
pick up every cup imma search every
notebook I'm gonna read every audio file
if I see high value on a thing I'm so
glad I never got that stories oh I got
that disease shout out to the companions
even though we we kind of killed them
shout out to Vasco that said absurd you
know you can give me give me some
because you are encumbered and you don't
talk don't talk mad smack to be like are
you really carrying more stuff yeah yeah
I gotta get and I want to give the Kim
in combat in the companion some credit
too is they've added at least the
companions I've been idle animations
when I do my but that's the best but
that's the game
yeah people like this dude he gonna stay
in this one
search every day
you can Hancock like I like that
attention the detail because to me it
shows that it felt make them feel human
like that's what someone would do like
it was really gonna take all that all
the styrofoam cups I'm ridiculous I'm
like oh reagent coolant I'm just doing
too much so that's me combat where I
felt it was very similar to King I came
in there I had the pistol and I was like
all right they just he had enough punch
for me I just wasn't doing it for me I
remember like free roaming and searching
the bass and finding and like some type
of energy shotgun that had a little
range and I was just a body then it
became like a shotgun style for me and I
started to do that then I started to get
in I have to do this game credit for the
the weapon types I had a gun calling on
Ryan like a laser weapon I had like a
deadbolt shotgun old hunting rifle yeah
a long range go I'm with soft didn't
like the melee as much I didn't think I
didn't get any cool Whaley weapons like
you did when you had weapons you talk
about you cutting you you wait and you
watch and you see the reaction yeah yeah
it's very definitely like in that any
type of the weapon that you get could
have that legendary exotic perk to it
that does plus more damage to robots
plus more damage to aliens you know some
type of give and take so I will give
that boost pack to me change the game
for me once I really mastered it and I
got I remember getting my first power
boost pack the one that's like a
trampoline where you can jump on top of
buildings that joint changed the game
for me I'm over there hovering around
looking around it was crazy and then my
platforming which then encouraged me to
go third personally like I want to see
when I'm landed I would like this is
fire so grab jump I want to give that
combat AI so I was right yeah sometimes
I like when you when because they
confident in the beginning when their
Shields is up oh yeah
again what I will say is even though the
con I would say it's serviceable right a
wicking that it feels I mean it was
something it feels good the shots the
impacts the Gunplay it feel like I
didn't need that I felt good on the
ground as far as that and then the last
thing I will say I want to give them
credit because again if you've done
wrong it's a very a lot of stealth stuff
the stealth AI is is God here there was
a quest that I had to infiltrate a
corporate building of my own
and oh no it was hard what are you doing
over there like from a lawyer and that's
what I learned about when you know
crouching and being you know out of
looking at the hidden media and seeing
it was it's very accurate even when it
comes to stealing as far as um that play
style that's what I learned about the
suppressed weapons getting my suppressed
kills and then back to the um actual
space combat I learned things to add it
because talking to him would you know
lasers and then I'm more of a missile
guy I like to get the lock on you know
do that kind of stuff but um I'm not
Adept yet there I just got to get more
turning and more more skills up but
overall I just want to say the combat
really impressed me I didn't think I
would like it as much as I I would and
then yeah you're not gonna lie to you
yeah like it's something about it and
then to your play style addict there's
something about the random nature of
going to another space jump looking
around who's the ships around or random
encounter someone talks and
when you would tell him I was like attic
addicts random things happen you seem
like you always in beef I know never
because I wasn't going I was only
staying to jumps that were familiar and
not going to anything I had a ship I had
a ship beg me to not blow it up once
like it was bad yeah I had people where
you you get Random Encounters where I
had to become a diplomat to save a
colony from one person was like we were
here we're the master oh you're talking
about the big shoe the big [__] they
were like they was like we're the best
in fact Andromeda crew we feel we
claimed this planet and you got to go
there and the guys you don't blow this
planet up and get this ship out of here
we go handle it but yeah we ain't gonna
do so bad I blew that ship up oh damn I
saw the option and that ship is huge
have you have you did the tour through
that man I blew it up before I went in
so like I said the last thing I'm saying
now Pastor Nick is just that especially
with the ship combat that the thing that
really adds a nice flavor to it where
from the guys that like the wing
commanders there's nothing more fun than
a dog fight where they go yeah you got
you now like when they talking to you
like that adds a nice little flavor to
it but Nick your overall thing and then
I know what attic man get finished I
know we go way all over the place yeah
yeah I I'm a snob when it comes to FPS
combat like I am like I am a snob like I
am your doom your Quake like I grew up
on that stuff right I've been playing
Wolfenstein and doom since I was three
years old like I'm an FPS snob through
and through and I played this damn game
in third person 98 of the time because I
loved it wow I loved it because like the
moment like the first moment I I boarded
a spaceship and one of those uh ecleptic
or electric dudes bum rushed me with the
with the shank and I shotgunned him I
was like oh wait we we shanking people
okay okay I'm like through my almost my
entire playthrough so far I'm using old
school weapons like I got your bolt
action rifles I got your old world
shotguns I've got a combat knife like I
will Full Tilt run into a spaceship with
nothing but a combat knife and kill the
entire crew wow that that is my jam
because I've been doing it's like
Fallout New Vegas it's like the combat
knife and the bolt action rifle out your
whole crew's gone wow but
um I really appreciated the jetpack
combat because jetpack combat and as
stupid as it sounds feels inherently
floaty in a lot of games there's very
few games that get boosted combat right
and I liked the boosted combat in
Starfield it felt natural like using
your Boost in like once you it took like
five minutes to get into the habit of
using it and then you were using it all
the time and you didn't really notice it
until you got into like you start
talking like the bigger boost packs you
start bouncing off the ceiling because
you're not paying attention
but I really like how natural felt it
didn't feel inherently floaty like you
didn't feel like you blast into the air
and then just kind of like floated there
and then the shooting felt bad
everything felt really Punchy and I
really liked how Punchy a lot of weapons
were I agree with you guys like the
pistols and they're they're okay some of
the later pistols definitely get a lot
better
um but the shotguns hit the late I
really liked how a laser gun safe
because yeah
laser guns are just pew pew pew pew pew
and they feel terrible to use but the
laser guns like hit in this game I do
wish there was dismemberment because man
once you get the explosive rounds on the
shotgun if there was dismemberment in
those ships yeah yeah I'd have to pay an
extra 10 000 credits to get the ship
before I sold it
um in terms of space combat I've never
really played any games in space combat
really really and truly so like this was
my first experience to dive into it and
I will fullmore admit I felt like an
idiot I was about five minutes for
messaging added because when you first
dock your first Starship I I sat I sat
there and I was like okay so we got
gauges and everything else I'm like so I
got like docked this thing like I've got
to land it right on the damn ship so I'm
sitting there for like
I'm gonna say optimistically 15 minutes
is probably closer to 25 where I've got
the engines on zero and I'm traveling
and waiting for a prompt yeah right
exactly waiting for the problem not
knowing that you got to press a on it to
tell it to bring it up today again to
Doc and I think like like I said before
that figure it out
that adds an extra 20 hours to this game
because the figure it out and you know
figure out how to do these guns figure
out how to dock figure out how to fight
in space it was three ships that kept
killing me and I'm like what the hell is
going on I got to jump on them this
there's no freaking way
until I figured out stop speeding just
slow down and attack and just sit there
in space and turn
this there's no indication on how to do
anything I think if anybody has any
criticism of this game it's that aspect
because there's no way in hell you're
supposed to be sitting there for 15 to
20 minutes trying to figure out how to
dock well let's see we don't have the
benefit this is always the fun part
about reviewing games is like people
that have played this post launch
they're gonna google they're gonna go
how do you document and I'm having that
issue right now I'm having that I was
gonna say I'm having the issue right now
with sea stars I'm literally talking to
developers asking where I go for the
side quests like there's all the tips
and tricks for stuff it was going to be
lit you going viral without making
videos you know yeah it's gonna be
channels dedicated to this game yeah
absolutely but what I love is
fun is
Bowl because I was like you know I I'm a
complete evil person when I'm on land
I'm gonna try to be nice in space
so the first ship that ever hails now
I'm outside the star system the ship
hails me he goes hey did you know that
we've been trying to contact you about
your ship's extended warranty yeah
what the telemarket is in space are you
serious yeah I shot it down yeah I did
no no at first I let that dude Rock but
after about the fifth sixth time I was
like nah man you you done yeah so I did
I did the same thing he was like Hey
we've been trying to reach you about
your ship's extended warranty you know
we can give you this a thousand year
warranty for this many credits and I was
like nah dude I'm good he's like all
right don't worry about it we'll get you
later and I'm like okay so I jump to the
next Plant and dude's right there and
he's like okay we're trying to talk to
you is that what you know what your
ship's mine I boarded that [__] I killed
every damn person in that [__]
hey Nick Nick let me ask you a question
I'm having this problem with dead bodies
still on my ship that I steal right oh
are you able to get rid of them because
you can't pick up bodies no you can't
you can't you can drag them you can drag
them you can't yep again uh but says the
game where it's like it's that
explicitly told I had to learn yeah hold
down hey you can drag them
I've just been treating it like you know
it's just the hood we got like a bunches
when I get to the cockpit I'm stepping
up
question are you are you registering
those ships I think once you once you
register it it's like a clean slate so
then they'll be gone I think I don't
know I haven't registered anything so
yeah did you register it yeah it'll be
brand spanking news feeding crew so they
send in the janitors
the John Wick cleaners all right we we
we're on the two hours of this yeah yeah
we only got one more topic after this
and that's a small topic I mean when it
comes to the space combat with me you
know um I got to the point where I was
getting so much cargo I stole cargo ship
and turned it into yes a Fire Ship yes
Auto turrets on it it is equivalent to a
tank floating in space so how big is
your cargo hole because I got one that
is three four it's three floors how much
three floors three floors damn yeah it's
a c ranked
beams
Oh no you're a different guy
well I've gotten to the point I could
show you clips of me just you know how
like at on the atmosphere of like big
big uh colonies there's like 10 15 ships
just floating around I could call I
could just go up and shoot and just kill
them all like because by the time they
by the time they take my Shields I've
killed enough of them where they're not
shooting me where my Shields have
regenerated oh wow yeah I haven't gotten
there yet but I I hope to be uh just
like you yeah so you know when it comes
to the space I would say out of
everything that the combat I'd offered
the space combat is by far the most
surprising to me I've I found myself
wanting to be a a civil person in the
world of of Starfield and then I got a
taste of that space combat and I'm like
I'm gonna be a pirate I'm a space pirate
like because I wanted to smoke you know
and what's funny is like I was telling
Carla he's like well there's just not a
lot of smoke going on around because
you're being civil but when everyone
hates you they smoke everywhere
all right so our last topic that we're
going to get into before we do like our
outros is the atmosphere you know
um we'll we'll combine this with the
story we can't talk a lot about stories
I didn't want to really put like a whole
thing dedicated to the story how did you
feel about the atmosphere this is a game
supposed to be in space so one would
think that the atmosphere and the
immersion for this game would be
different than your average game and
then you know talk a little bit about
your overall impressions of the story
don't go into any kind of detail just
your impressions of how much you got so
far we'll start with Nick
uh yeah I know really really quickly I
really like the atmosphere it's really
weird because like inherently when you
see a lot of sci-fi and space it's a lot
like generic like you know Star Wars ask
you know space suits but I really like
the flavor of if you land on a civilized
plan like you got dudes rocking cowboy
hats you got guys wearing baseball caps
you got you know there's variety there
um I I like the fact that you know
there's towns that felt like like old
western settlements there was towns that
felt like you know Sleek through Year
3000 cities there's a lot of environment
I do love the variety of planets and the
challenges that come with those
different planets when you start talking
about you know dealing with
um
you know bad atmosphere
um fire vents gas all this other stuff
that you you start to deal with it's
really cool and adds to the immersion of
you don't really know what you're
dealing with if you don't scan the
planets at first like I was Landing
blind a lot of the time and I stopped
doing that because there's plants I
landed I was like I don't want anything
to do with any of this because I wasn't
paying attention I landed on a an ice
planet where I basically walked out and
I watched my health meter start just
deteriorating and I was like I came to
Planet first yeah so I I got to have a
skin in the planet and everything else
but what I love most about it basically
to just Bunch it all up is the fact that
the main storyline is enticing but I
never felt like the side content took
away from me being in the main story
like I always feel like there's this
disconnect when you're playing Bethesda
Studio games where like you know it's
like 5 different stories that don't have
nothing to do with each other exactly
like I can look at my Xbox profile
history I bought Skyrim on launch day I
didn't kill I'll do it until two and a
half years later
because I forgot I forgot he existed I
legit was like oh I'm doing this I'm
doing this I forgot that there was a
main storyline so I literally went oh
okay we're gonna walk through and I slap
the dude three times and killed him and
called it a day and same kind of thing
with Fallout 4 it's like the side quests
were more interesting than the main
quests in the long ways but I really
felt like the side quests enhanced the
main story everything built on
it built on itself in a way that was
meaningful and you never felt like you
weren't doing something you should be
doing
and when there's moments of urgency it
was done within a layered Quest so that
you were doing the 11 steps of that
quest in a section and that's like oh
hey you have time to go out and do
something work Hive at a standstill here
there was never like you know we need to
save the world and then you're like oh
no I'm gonna go
you guys have fun with the end of the
world like I haven't found a point to
that yet uh but with that being said
I've spent way more time doing the side
content because every damn time I land
somewhere someone has to open their
mouth I get a new Quest marker and I'm
like I need to go over here and it's
good it's gonna take me 300 hours to
beat this game because I can't focus
there's so much side content and it's
good side content it's not like you know
go here collect object a place object a
and you know NPC hand B and yeah your
quest is over there's a lot of
interesting stuff and there's side
quests that engage you into the weapon
crafting into you know using all the
different aspects of the game so you can
literally as addict proved you can go
through the entire game and not craft
anything you don't have to do that they
don't force you to do that you've got
something better for you Nick I don't
even have a crew on my ship
that's Jesus listen listen the only
thing addict apparently did was kill
everyone everything but somebody's dog
[Laughter]
then he had John Wick coming after him
but but I think that's what's great
about Starfield is it's like if you want
to rush through this story you
absolutely could like if you wanna if
you're here for the main quest line
that's what you want to do it perfectly
caters to you doing that if you more
like to immerse yourself in the world
you can do that Starfield feels like the
Love Letter to what Bethesda always
wanted to do and like they want to cater
to as many different people as they can
yeah and I think Starfield has finally
nailed that where you know you want to
run off and be a space pirate be a space
pirate you want to do the main questline
do the main quest line you want to be a
scientific researcher and go mine on a
bunch of planets go do that
they don't care and I I really love that
open-endedness about about Starfield in
general it's just it's so brilliantly
done because it's engaging no matter
what you're doing
well
I'm sorry got it
um
mood
and I heard you know Todd keep saying
mood mood mood I think this is his
magnum opus
and I've said this you know coming into
this game
I think this is a seminal everything
that he has learned throughout the years
and
was able to wrap it up into a nice clean
boat as best as he possibly could
giving whatever limitations that there
is with uh excuse me the engine that he
has going on right now and uh AI
I think the only Innovation that he
would do uh after this game would
probably be Ai and companions right
because he have seemed to have conquered
every aspect of it
um
this gives a feeling of Star Wars
and when I say Star Wars Star Wars
learned how to
not be over reliant on Tech
in digital they they have this balance
of analog world in a digital world all
at the same time and it seems that Todd
realized if he goes full
digital
then you have to worry about robots
being sentient and then that becomes
something totally different right it
changes your game in that aspect so if
you keep the analog aspect of it like
when you go into the ship and you're
hitting levers and stuff like that
but still have it digital
you keep a happy medium
whereas you see the space launching
shuttle when you when you land on the
moon it's a feel it's a it's a mood it
feels current and it feels old when you
get an old style gun from Earth and
you're trying to figure out what the
hell happened to Earth what's going on
with Earth
your your mind can lead you down
different paths right so you're your own
author yeah there's a main storyline and
there's a thread that you can go follow
but on your way to these planets people
start talking
and you'll listen if you stay quiet and
you just listen
a quest to pop up because they'll talk
about somebody that needs some help
someplace else that's on that planet and
if you want to go to the bar and talk to
the guy
it'll lead you on a path and these are
not normal paths like Nick was saying
these side quests have many branch and
tendrils
and it leads through fantastic different
places I jump from
Galaxy to Galaxy
fixing satellites to help
uh strength well they weren't stranded
they just weren't able to communicate
with each other it was it was like uh
fighting families and I had to fix those
con I had to do persuasion to get one
person to work with the other ones
because one guy was sheisty and I had to
find out if I was able to trust these
people but
it was like 15 different steps for this
side quest
and it led me to different parts of the
Galaxy where I got different quests from
there too
that I came back and I finished this
Quest so I say this to say
it's the main story is there and you can
follow it and it's ambiguous enough that
it's not a threat in the world like like
Nick was saying like oh Gannon is here
but uh I'm gonna go float over here
oh the the Moon is close and it's about
to crash into the Earth but I'm gonna go
collect Mass right it's not like that
this is this is
we don't know what the threat is with
these uh things that we have to find
but we also know that there's other
things in the Galaxy that we can be
doing and you can join different
factions and you can join different
groups and you can go get a job whereas
in this job you can lie down people
enjoy dead beats I was getting my
Breaking Bad on one job
it's literally Breaking Bad
brosn Pirates I can rock it be on it
is a bounty on my head because I killed
those settlers that I gave the water to
but it's stuff like that if you do
something it will May lock you off to a
particular part of the Galaxy or if you
go there this game has so many different
parts so many different moving parts
that the side quest becomes quests
within themselves and it's how you want
to play I oh I just felt by talking to
all you guys out all four of you guys
that everybody's played different yeah
attic has played in a manner that is
conducive to how attic likes to play and
he he has been
staunched in his way he didn't go
collect book bags in Spider-Man he just
finished it from beginning to end
and it's the same way here he decided
that he didn't want to get companions he
didn't want to craft anything I'm still
level 12.
and I'm still doing all this great stuff
so the game the mood and feel of the
game is old and new
but it's large
and small enough in scope where when I'm
playing it I don't get overwhelmed when
I'm doing whatever I'm doing I don't get
overwhelmed when I go into systems then
I learn the systems I don't get
overwhelmed in the beginning I started
getting overwhelmed and then I slowed it
down to a pace that was comfortable for
myself opposed to trying to keep up with
everybody else so it's it's crafted in a
way that I could be playing this game
for years and still never get to
whatever the ending is because I have
over 50 side quests that's already on my
docket
no
solve your thoughts sir
um I got I have about 73 hours in the
game
and I'm level 16.
um
I'm not even joking like level 60 shifts
are worth like 550x XP yes yes pirate
addict Pirates murder addict
genocide addict yeah I wouldn't go to
the genocide addict don't give me that
kind of brownie points yeah I mean
clearly ain't nobody survive anybody in
your your space cluster if they move
around they gonna get popped they
breathe wrong
it is heartless out here
I think for atmosphere initially I was a
little worried about the atmosphere
because when you look at previous bgs
games it's all focused on one world
right one world where everything is sort
of
if it's Fallout if it's Oblivion if it's
Skyrim it's everything adheres to a
certain like something happened in this
place that everything was affected by
and all of it kind of falls into the
same umbrella of weirdness right here
Todd said okay no every time you get on
your ship and you go someplace else the
weirdness is different but at the same
time I have to try to make that feel
cohesive
and
for me
every for me it is a beautiful thing
every time I get into the ship and it
tell and it asks you hey what do you
want to do walk around the ship you want
to take off and then when you take off
there's that cinematic
the grab jump is beautiful the Cinematic
when you when you lift off and then when
you're in space and you go from place to
place I'm gonna make this comparison and
it may be unfair right let's go I I
wished I wished it was more like no
man's sky and that it was seamless and
it's like I could do all of that in real
time and it's not necessarily cinematic
because it would have made the world
feel that much more cohesive but
considering how big this game is how
crafted a lot of the game is and not
procedurally generated there it makes
sense that you have those cinematic
moments for those type of things
but I think for me every time I land on
a planet whether it's a populated planet
that you know is a bespoke create
created planet with cities and things of
that nature or whether it's one of those
that you know is probably particularly
procedurally generated when I land on
them you see
hey you're going to start seeing the
same type of structures and the same
type of missions on those types of
planets it's like hey go fetch this
thing over here there might be some
pirates in this structure or something
like that the structures that are on the
planet start looking similar the
structures that are alike they're
literally built to like so the you know
the layouts and everything are alike
right and you may find one or two
interesting quests on there but it's
mostly about Gathering resources
Gathering you know trying to find a cool
weapon that might be on the planet or
whatever
um but every now and again you will find
a story thread that takes you on a side
mission to King's Point that is
interesting it's well acted
um the you know the voice acting the
characters emote in a way that I I think
you know it's still you still a little
weird and uncanny but it's still more
than what you've seen in previous
Bethesda games where it's like you see
more emotion in the faces and you and
and the voice acting really goes a long
way towards making you feel for certain
plights of these characters
so
in taking all that into consideration I
go out and I'm like you know what
this is this is really special because
it's super difficult to be able to
create that that that that that that
feeling of of surprise and wonder every
time you land on a planet because you
don't know what it's going to be there
and I don't I specifically don't scan
planets before I land on them for that
reason to give myself that sense of
surprise when I land and I'm like okay I
land and I'm out of your mind yeah I'm
definitely scared
because of because of how I collect
everything I'm always prepared I have
15 suits oh my 20 some odd helmets I
have a lot I'm prepared for pretty much
any scenario that I'm faced with so I
land blindly and every time I land and I
walk out that ship it's like wow what am
I gonna see what's the floor on this
planet what's the phone on this man am I
going to see a new species of animal on
here uh you know what what's happening
so even in those procedure to generate
moments for me and the type of player I
am when you think about how I play Like
A Red Dead how I play a GTA how I play
any open world game especially bgs games
it's those moment to moment things that
define the experience for me and I think
they did a great and I was worried about
it initially but they've done a great
job of giving you that feeling of
vastness but like to King's Point when
you're doing something you feel very
much in it and even if it's a crafted
experience or if it's a more
procedurally generated experience it's
still something that draws you into that
word world because it's like you know
very light on the story but basically
this is 300 years in the future right it
has that future retro look that that
sort of bgs games are known for kind of
in the vein of an outer worlds where
it's futuristic but it's old school
right
um
and basically the Earth Humanity had to
leave earth right we had to leave Earth
and now we're going out to this in in
into the into space and it is the I this
idea of like hey
we are we we we got what we needed from
space in order to be to be able to live
we settled certain places but we reached
the point that we stopped that we
stopped now it's on you to continue and
to find out what's out there and that
Intrigue just that threat alone speaks
beautifully to whatever the overarching
story is that they're trying to tell in
addition to speaking beautifully to the
moment to moment very nuanced very sort
of minutia uh filled gameplay that that
the game has and it's just it they leave
it up to you and they've always been the
masters of leaving it up to you this is
your story you're crafting it we're just
giving you the tools to do it
um and they they've done from what I've
seen they've done a great job I'd like
us to talk about when we wrap up
completely performance on all on all
systems because I know people want to
hear about that but um yeah I think that
I think I think they got it and I'm very
again I don't I don't know anything
about the story I went in and I did what
I do with these games and I I just clean
out every room that I that I see
um but um yeah Todd Todd got another one
I got another one you know I'll jump in
to follow up um this was this was a very
interesting one for me to start off from
a story standpoint because I got to be
honest with y'all
I actually was a little worried in the
beginning because I didn't feel the
story how they started with me captured
me enough to to know that I would want
it could happen to some degree yeah
because look I'm gonna be honest look
I'ma but that's the guy as far as the
oblivious not that their main stories
are not good but the strength of their
games to me has always been the factions
and side quests and the stuff that
really Meats it out and then kind of
like what Nick said like when you do
main quests and stuff like that you get
a payoff and it feels good but it's
never been like okay I'm playing this as
a linear game to do the main thing and I
have to admit like the first three four
hours felt slow two not two to three
hours felt slow I felt it was their baby
way of a tutorial of trying to get me
acclimated to some of these complex
systems that they clearly got a ton of
right so I'm like all right when I got
to new Atlantis then it felt like
classic Oblivion in Skyrim where things
open up people talking questions
questions popping okay okay okay so now
when I get to that part I start Diva I
start doing the Nick I start deviating I
ain't doing because this is a Bethesda
game and your main story gonna be I but
it ain't gonna be why I'm here I'm doing
this so I did all that stuff into my
benefit
when I finally did come back to main
quest because I was like you know what
all right [__] you gotta do suck like
you they play for like three days
without touching the main question yo
Sarah's like when are we going back to
the lodge yeah
imagine being the AI trying to find this
mysterious like solution and and then
it's just like we going to Mars
she was bad because I refused it I
wouldn't even meet Harley any of the
members of constellation I wasn't doing
any of that so did I finally have to say
about 25 30 hours I'm like all right God
you gotta at least see what's going on
and I'm not gonna front like it's King
said it best like the way they doing it
first of all from the amount of story
I've played this is the most polished
main story they have ever done right
where I am now oh I shouldn't have been
putting this off this is really really
good stuff but obviously I can't spoil
I'm not gonna spoil it we're gonna
respect embargo but I I was really
impressed and the fact that it it fit
nice like King said because it didn't
feel like oh my God imminent threat
Ganon is here destroyed because that
feels Faker if you're not taking care of
imminent threat are you going to the
club
stealing ships with addict all day right
so it's like so that part you know I
would say definitely it was a nice mix
so yeah once I got that going the the
only thing I do want to talk about that
I know we're going to talk about
technical stuff but I do have to address
this this will be the rub for some
people
it this is a hardcore
do everything you want to do kind of
game right it does not hold your hand if
there's things out there to be done it
could be done if you put in the work and
you figure it out however if you're a
casual and you might want to get your
hand held on certain things you could go
a couple of hours without doing much of
advancing anything right and that will
be the rub for some people like you know
if you try to play this like a
traditional game and say hey I'm just
gonna you know look over the horizon and
and that's how story is going to be
presented to me all the time it may not
hit you in your particular session for
that day right it's so broad it's so
deep but it's one of those things when
you do refine a playing style and you do
find okay I like to do this I like to do
that and then you start engaging in
activities or you find things that
supplement that it becomes the most
addicting game I have ever played and
that's when I knew the magic of
Starfield was in me because I'm like man
I cannot stop so that's what I just want
to say about that and um we'll talk out
about the technical stuff performance
but I just wanted to get that before I
give it to addicts
when it comes to this the only thing
that I'm disappointed is I feel like you
know the the vast scale and obviously
they had to do it because you're in
space you're in the universe they got to
feel something uh but I do think that
hurt them in a lot of ways because I do
feel I went to a lot of planets
and I just felt like it would have been
better at that plan it wasn't there now
I understand in real life it would be
like that if we went out and we found a
ship and we started hyper jumping
everywhere A lot of these planets gonna
be empty but this is a video game
there's got to be a good middle ground
and I feel like they hit the middle
ground for the most part I think the
part that I was just a little
disappointed with the atmosphere is like
and it's not necessarily the game's
fault I got too spoiled with like Mass
Effect where I felt like all these
different civilizations like I kind of
expected that a little bit you know what
I'm saying uh one thing I do want to
point out is like I'm a little
disappointed with Bethesda for not
putting more Easter eggs in the game
I've ran into some but you got like
iconic creatures that's been in you know
Fallout Elder Scrolls you could have put
them in this game on a random generated
Planet like imagine going into a planet
you go into a cave and it's um
what's uh what is I I know it's on the
top of my head death Clause it's a
deathclaw and there's death claws in
like a cave like look sure that would be
a little bit out of the out of the
atmosphere thing but it's just like that
would have been a nice little Easter egg
where you see like a random deathclaw
cave or something like that that's just
nitpicking to the degree but I do feel
like with the vast majority of stuff
that Bethesda and Microsoft owns they
could have filled up these up these
planets a little bit better for a little
bit more Easter egg thing I think you
know we would be seeing a lot of that
going up on on on Twitter and stuff
I gotta I gotta agree with you guys they
they did it man you know this even
though I I have my Knicks with this game
my nitpicks
I never put the game down I I had to
force myself to put the game down so I
can finish another game review that game
and you know it's it's good man it's
good I think that you know for the most
part the atmosphere emerges on point you
know the combat's on point the quests
are on point we didn't really talk a
whole lot about it because I'm too
scared of like going uh breaking embargo
anything but the faction quests are
pretty fun too yeah it's a package
mm-hmm no absolutely and last thing I'll
say and fully rap is I do want to
address what solve alluded to what I
consider the space travel controversy
that I'm hearing and what I mean by is
that one of the things that annoyed me
at first is when you if you're in a
solar system right I thought I'd have
the ability to if I just set course and
I go to planet Mars I'll get there
you'll get there but what will happen is
you're gonna have to press that scanner
and then you're gonna have to press the
button and then you're gonna land or
exactly or it'll if you want to go from
Mercury to Earth you're gonna press the
button and then it's gonna do a little
cinematic animation within the solar
system that will then take you now that
may rub some people the wrong way who
are expecting the fly anywhere no man ex
you know Sky it is kind of fake fake
right exploring it it is a like a fake
barrier between each thing now don't get
me wrong from a technical standpoint I
understand there's zillions of planets
and zillions I get it you know I'm
saying but I'm just saying for the for
the Casual they may get frustrated you
know saying because if you don't want to
start Slaughter menus yes and a lot of
pausing and loading now where the game
wins me back over with that is nothing
more beautiful than when you do
something go to a planet explore you
infiltrate he did all this stuff and
then the worst thing of the game is like
all right now I gotta go back walking my
way out this base like oh no you if
you've been there before you can fast
travel press that start you fast travel
you could go you don't even have to be
at your ship you can faster
same thing with the scale you press the
skin you don't have to travel there
before
sometimes yeah correct you can you can
at least do the jump start to get to the
planet but you can't get to like the
locations on the planet yeah
I've never I've never experienced that
because I'm always in Comfort oh yeah
you can't do that yeah okay I've learned
that
um because through trial and error like
I didn't know how to jump from Galaxy to
Galaxy I didn't know how to follow
missions I learned just go to the
mission board click the mission and
press X to to set course that wasn't
told to me nope that was something that
I had to learn but when I went outside
of those steps it became more convoluted
it was a walk over to this place or walk
out of the cave or or walk to my ship
instead of press to my ship or set
course to Galaxy yes right so when
anybody's complaining
you can fly to that Galaxy if you choose
I hope you got enough gas like if you're
going to play it that way you got a
haircut
see but this is the thing you can't fly
from said Galaxy to said Galaxy without
setting a course right if you do it that
way and if you have underneath between
them you have to go to the play tween
planet right yes you have to set of
course you have to find the course so
you can play that seafaring stuff you
anybody that's complaining about that
that's an that's that's a that's a
non-starter you can play that Mr I want
to fly the Galaxy all you like or you
can hit the button and let it take you
there you can do the autopilot when I
drive on the highway and I'm going
really far I put my car on cruise
control and I go that way I'm not
bothering with the pedals I'm not
bothered with the brakes and my car has
this little nice feature if I lean too
much in a lane my car will Rumble Rumble
wake me up or whatever so again you can
do it on autopilot or you can do it
manual and it's up to you this imaginary
barriers they are not there guys this
this thing is really and I hear y'all
flying into the planet flying out to the
planet that's cool if you want to know
man Sky it up and and do that Todd said
that became a little too much
right you gotta land it you got to do
this I understood that he he wants the
the fun aspects of space as far as
fighting and dog fighting yeah thank God
he ain't put no fuel like a fuel because
that would have made it on that one yeah
that would have taken the fun out of it
completely oh I can't get there and I
didn't have a good middle ground where
this is a game and some realistic things
will make it less fun so let's go ahead
and move on to our final thoughts you
know uh we I do want to answer a couple
patreon member questions uh most of them
I look through them we actually answered
through them but there's a couple good
ones but you know
first off King I want to hear from you
on this part right you know well we've
all screamed from the hill when it comes
to Starfield but you you you were the
general King and now
you got a golden gun called Starfield
so but first off you know
did you do you think this game met your
expectations of what what's the future
for Xbox now
he
wanted to get
you can't play this on Playstation it's
just gonna get you to trade your
PlayStation and it might it might know
with a game like this regardless where
it scores Metacritic wise I do think
it's going to be a high 80s early it's
going to be a high 90. so regardless
where it scores I think it's going to be
a positive receiving game with this
momentum where do you think Xbox goes
with it
this is the jumping off point
this is this is yo you know the
Blackjack like
when a dude walk in a room and he got
the Blackjack you know how no matter
where they hit you in the head of the
Blackjack you going out
this is the Blackjack they got a
blackjack this is it right here I'm so
happy that that Phil winning this film
when he found out that he was trying to
get this game Star Phil just uh it just
uh through
uh Boulders gate three for the most sold
game on Steam just later I figured out
anyway I wasn't paying that boat just
getting on my mind
um
everybody sitting there
what did it do differently anyway I'm in
space see me in space
this is the Blackjack
and this this is the Blackjack you could
only get over here this is get it out of
the lane this is the best get down or
lay down Phil winner over there said
oh hell no we gotta buy them
I don't care imagine the PlayStation
would have got that exclusivity no I
don't imagine I don't imagine I don't
imagine but what I do know is now now
we're not playing if ands or butts we
ain't in that land no more this is the
Blackjack this is the this is night
night time right so
yo Todd you got one man you got one you
got one and and then in a year where I
thought Spider-Man was gonna have game
of the year it was gonna be it was gonna
happen nope here come Ty with the
Blackjack again he on Deck
this this is a system seller this is a
console mover this is a subscription
service changer when you have this game
that's going to deliver your
subscription service and perpetuity and
drop day and day there is absolutely no
reason for every gamer not to be playing
this game at some point in time to give
their opinion I don't care what side of
the fence you're on I don't care about
anything that anybody's talking about
this game is that game and for it is it
it reminds me of the LeBron James we
knew LeBron James was coming out of high
school all the accolades and stuff was
put on his back what's he going to live
up to that
all this stuff was put on Starfield you
saw what redfall did and you're like
I don't know
my baby you know if stuff might happen
nah man he he lived up to every
expectations uh that was set forth and
and I just say it's a couple little
technical things yes
and stuff like that like my Sarah she
was floating in the sky she's doing some
stuff and then um when I was playing on
my series X I had a little bit more uh
slow down there I think it had more to
do with resolution because when I was
playing on my Series S
no issues absolutely no issues and um I
I migrate from in between and it saves
us
yep so that that was good so I knew if I
go over here I could do that I go over
here I could do that I can just get my
gaming in I gauge my games on what
controls the Mind share in my head
if I go to sleep thinking about the game
and I get up thinking about the game you
got a winner
the game took time away from my fortnite
gaming
that's huge yeah that's you because
fortnite just excuse me just came out
with a new season now
and it's Immaculate it's incredible
I played a couple of a couple of hours
and I was like yo all right I love you
guys I we had just got a uh Crown Royal
and I was like yo a crown Victory I was
like yo I gotta go I gotta put in my um
my Starfield time they was like wow it
must be really good I said I can't say
nothing about it but I'm smiling talk to
you later
um this game is that game and it's going
to consume certain people I'm like some
of my um hosts here I go in every room
and I touch everything
I think there's going to be people
that's going to play like attic that's
going to play like myself that's going
to play like Nick or play like solve or
play like COG
and then play like themselves
but there's something for everyone in
this game I don't I I find it very hard
to believe
if a person picks up this game if you
like third person shooters play third
person if you like first person shooters
play first person if you like space
flying go in space and fly the only
thing that's missing here is driving a
car
and yeah
we need some mods we need some vehicles
solve your thoughts man this is I gotta
go saying this is the big one
you know did it live up to the to the
weight for you you know what is it being
for Xbox and your parting thoughts on
any issues or just overall feeling yeah
I think
I think they they got it they got it um
this is a game that it's it's a heart
this is a really hard undertaking when
you think about it like these type of
games period because you're trying to
make a game that appeals to everybody
you're trying to create a game that's
play style is so broad that appeals to
any number of different people and how
they want to play and who they want to
become in that world
that's not an easy thing to do that's
why these games take a decade to make
you know that's why you know you have to
make concessions we're like yeah it
doesn't does it look like the last of us
know it's not gonna look at least maybe
not for 20 years it'll look like the
last of us not gonna happen but what it
does very special is it's it creates a
world for you to inhabit and do what you
want when you want to do it how you want
to do it for the most part and yeah this
story and the story is usually going to
be pretty good at sort of defining the
world but at the end of the day the
moment to moment stuff the adventures
that I had they're all yours
and I really do think to King's Point it
really is the type of game where
it's a hardcore RPG through and through
and there is a lot of quality of life
stuff that I wish they did sort of do uh
little things I think like when it comes
to like
hey just uh being able to transfer stuff
from one character to another yeah the
fact that you you have to go go over
here put the stuff in the hall whatever
um I found that I like certain stuff
didn't transfer from ship to ship which
is weird that might have been it's been
a glitch
things like that
um
but in terms of performance of the the
game this is their most polished game
yet
and and that's saying a lot like you say
it a lot for these type of games where
So Many Factors so many variables come
into play
um I'm playing on PC
I'm playing a high-end PC at ultra
settings
um I also have help with g-sync and
things like that to smooth out the game
the gameplay the game plays very nicely
very smoothly what's disappointing about
the PC releases it is very very little
in terms of options there's very basic
options one row of options
um you get FSR 2.0 I'm gonna like that I
already know you're gonna be very upset
and we had a big update today we there
was an update today so I I'm thinking
that's the day one update yeah that was
a that was a day one update I'm thinking
and I didn't see anything change I
didn't see fsr3 in the options or
anything like that so
um it's very basic in that so
um
but again the game ran fairly well
although I will say this I had
about 25 crashes to desktop right just
freeze crash the desktop and I boot it
right back up and then I'd play fine for
the next eight hours right and I didn't
have issues in that regard I had very
few of the weird you know Bethesda Jank
issues that are fun right like you could
walk into one of the funny things is
that I would go see people like Sarah or
whatever
um or the guy what is his name
Lieutenant Tawala who's a part of the
Vanguard and brings you in so you meet
him the first time you have their
interactions you they send you on your
missions you come back everybody's balls
yeah
everybody's bald I'm like okay I guess
we do it isn't it did you catch the one
where everyone's face disappeared it was
just eyeballs no no I didn't get that no
no I cast the one with the with the legs
you go to Italian nobody got the legs
just the top no
yeah I've seen people uh bodies cut in
half like through the floor right but
very very few though very few like this
is no cap whatsoever this at launch this
is their most College product ever did
you imagine what it was last year
and you imagine this game without
Microsoft buying them and giving them
more time to polish the game up yeah
they would have released it a year ago
and it would have been
they would have been yeah they would
have dealt with whatever that backlash
was and then it would have got to where
it is but I think where where this game
is special specifically for Xboxes
it is that game that is like hey for the
first time in a long time
it is a system seller right this is this
is the one to say hey man this game you
get this you get Game Pass you get an
Xbox you're gonna have the next game
from the makers of Oblivion from the
makers of Skyrim you in Fallout once you
hear that
and and the product is good it's not a
Fallout 76 right and even then when you
think about the tale of these games
another thing that's important is that
you have great games right you have you
have your your Spidermans you have your
God of Wars you have your ghost of
tsushimas the thing about those games is
that they have a moment and it's brief
because they're very narrative based
they aren't these games that have these
super long tails because the the
Zeitgeist around them is a month or two
right everybody's played it whatever
this is a game where the Zeitgeist
around it is literally years because
it's always something right and the
initials like guys is easily six months
because the King's Point maybe the
person is not attracted this game
immediately then realizes wait I have
Xbox I have Game Pass why don't I just
try it oh my god I've never been this
obsessed with a game that allows me to
go in and if I love styrofoam I'm gonna
pick up every styrofoam thing in this in
this game and I don't want to do
anything else and that's fine
um so I I just think this the game's
ability to capture the Zeitgeist and
hold it for a long time because of the
type of game it is and because the level
of quality that the game is in relation
to all of the hits they've had in the
past really put it in a position to
really really really take over the
conversation
uh in a way that we haven't seen an Xbox
game do in a really long time at least
in a positive way right we had a little
bit of it at the launch of Halo a little
bit at the launch of Halo infinite and
then it died down quick and you know
obviously redfall didn't do what we
wanted it to do but this is this is it
this is what it wanted to do yeah it did
I think it's still doing what it wants
to do but um
but I said Todd and the team got this
one they they focused on what they do
best and I was worried about this Todd's
saying you know what oh I'm just gonna
do bigger and more right but he did
bigger and more
in in a way that only their expertise
can allow them to do which is okay
bigger and more but it still has to feel
coherent and important and part of this
one universe that when you're doing
something intimate it feels intimate
when you're doing something broad it
still feels like it's manageable because
again it's it's all it all feels like it
feels beautifully in this one umbrella
right and so they got it man they they
did it I I haven't had a chance to sit
down and play 75 hours of a game in so
long and you know the the opportunity to
sit here and do that and then to want to
be there and do when I looked at the
count I was like no I didn't do that 75
hours what and those planets take a
minute to walk around especially when
you don't scan them before you go into
them
I am collecting those Resources by hand
sir that's what I'm doing that's right
that's what I need hey uh we need Todd
we need a a Mako DLC yeah we definitely
need a makeup
yes I I really do think it's uh has a
potential to be a game changer and it's
a a very very good game and we've only
skimmed the surface of it I don't think
anybody here has finished it right no no
no no okay yeah no Nick oh let's get
your impressions as far as worth the
wait final Impressions and you know what
does it mean for Xbox going forward good
bad to hold on and then I'll end after
you look the like I've been playing
Bethesda games for a long long time I I
did a little like history digging for
the sake of it and like I got 24 days in
Fallout 4. I've I've got like 14 days of
Fallout New Vegas and probably at least
30 days in Fallout 3. and I didn't even
want to look at my Skyrim
um
the hours I was on probation when Skyrim
came out I don't want to look at what
those numbers were but the thing is is
like
I've been playing these games a long
time and the hardest thing when you're a
Bethesda fan is getting people over the
Hub because you gotta tell them like the
game's really amazing but like you just
gotta get past the bugs
all the systems and the janky combat and
now with Starfield I really feel like
all I gotta do is be like hey once you
get past the first couple hours of
systems you're gonna have a great time
it's not like hey you're gonna fall
through the planet like nine times you
know your gun's gonna go backwards
you're gonna drop stuff you know it's
gonna be a terrible like performance
experience you're gonna you know drop
down to 13 frames when you enter a house
you know it's it's none of that like as
much as I love Skyrim at launch that
game was an absolute disaster piece at
launch and like I played it on PS3
originally and like
oh no oh no no
and like I switched to 360. that was one
of the uh one of the things that made me
go you know what I think I need an Xbox
because this ain't good this thing
yeah but
but
overall what I've enjoyed so far about
Starfield is that it's vast and it makes
me sad because I don't have the time
that I used to have it's important to a
game like this like while I was playing
like it really blew my mind because like
Fallout 76 came out I I try to forget
Fallout 76 I still have 100 hours in
Fallout 76 I wish I could forget them
but
but like when it's amazing how much of a
journey it's been for Bethesda because I
was sitting there thinking about like
Fallout 4 came out in 2015. uh Fallout 4
came out when my daughter was born
because I remember when my daughter was
born and she's my my first she would sit
on my lap while I would play Fallout 4
and I'm playing through it and just
having a blast you know a father for the
first time everything else and now I'm
playing Star field I've got my son who's
my third third kid now I'm sitting on my
lap while I'm exploring this world and
it's it feels generational almost and
it's it's really it's really cool to
have those kind of experiences to link
back to a game and that's been that much
of a journey for them because like in my
mind they went from Fallout 4 to
Starfield we're just gonna pretend
okay that should not be named like the
thing is like if you play Starfield and
you play Fallout 76 you're going to
realize a lot of these systems a lot of
the things you guys love about Starfield
was fostered in Fallout 76 in DLC and
add-ons a lot of the updates to Fallout
76 are core mechanics now in Starfield
that they test trialled in Fallout 76
and I love that they had a game where
they can fool around play with it get
player feedback on what their fan base
actually wants to learn from failure
yeah yeah and I'm glad they had that
learning curve
gotta forget they said that we're not
gonna let you know what's in the bag
just
100.
yeah
continue Nick
but I think the main if you want to make
it
take away from
this is cool
that is the thing that people have been
wanting from Xbox for so long
consistency and quality now consistency
is going to be what the next game that
Xbox releases looks like so that's going
to be Forza Motorsport we'll see shortly
how that looks but the thing is the star
field is Microsoft helped publish a
polished Bethesda game I need people to
understand the points polish empathize
the game don't go together
I love the Fest I've been a fan for 20
plus years but like polished Bethesda
those are not side-by-side things like
that is not something that is common and
I'm glad I hope going forward that this
is the quality that they deliver I was
playing on Xbox series X so my
performance obviously the 30 frames like
I would love for to be 60 frames
obviously if you get if you're playing
at 30 frames you're always gonna wish
you were playing 60 frames that's just a
fact of life period end of the story but
with that being said I appreciate the
fact that I could be in a spaceship or
in space fighting all these people and
everything else and my frame rate's
solid it's not yeah dipping yes I'm not
shooting lasers it's definitely one of
the better 30 frame games
yeah very stable the only frame rate
hiccups I had was in the cinematics when
I was leaving a planet and in which case
I was like I didn't really care because
it was like it would I have like frame
rate stutters when leaving a planet I'm
like I that doesn't affect me at all
Mars was when when the train I like get
off the train or something oh yeah I was
like why did why the train doing that
like everybody else is fine it happens
on my rig too it was like a two
the worst one I had is everyone's arms
getting replaced by their legs coming
off oh my God no I had no nothing like
that
yeah I came out and I turned and look at
Sarah's beside me and her legs are up
where her mouth
why is you up there like what are you
doing he just stood up there talking to
me look at you sir yeah I I just I had
the same couple of ones like I had Samco
for me was the roach of my adventure
because every time I turned around he
was on top of my damn spaceship I'm like
dude get down what are you doing up
there but like the thing is is those
kind of bugs it's it's something I talk
about a lot in a lot of the reviews I
write there's bugs that bother you and
there's bugs that you'll find funny and
you like frame rate performance bugs
screen tearing
um you know lighting issues and stuff
like that that stuff isn't inherently
funny but ai's glitching out and arm
disappearing
um all of a sudden someone catapulting
into the sky I stabbed a dude
in a city and for some reason he
catapulted me
it was on a ship though like I went to
board something and I guess it glitched
out and it's and it like threw my ship
in the air like it was so far up I
couldn't see the ship that I was trying
to board anymore
yeah and like my favorite ones I we were
talking about the melee guys that run at
you and this guy comes barreling around
the car me he goes ah he's battling at
me I'm trying to pull out a weapon and
they fell through the floor and
disappeared I was like no oh wow I'm
having an experience
yo I had none of this
and I'm not Kevin because if I did boy I
recorded what I did and I showed you
guys yeah automatically deleted it
because I don't want that thing to get
out by mistake if I ever encountered
something like that my review will be
completely different review I guess with
me
it's just like it's a great game man
they did what they supposed to Todd
Howard uh deliver for the majority of
the expectations that I had I would say
that Starfield met the expectations that
I had uh for the most part there were
certain things that I wanted like a
little bit more filled world but even
with that it's little things at this
point like the amount of fun I had being
a space pirate was way more fun than the
nitpicks that I had as far as Xbox I
think they you if anything now they need
to look forward and they need to be like
Hellboy got to come out gotta be quality
I don't care if we got to delay that
another six months we can't go from
Starfield to another like mid-range
between Starfield and redfall like
quality Quality quality we don't care
how long these games take to come out
they got to be quality because you got
to get yourself in that PlayStation
mindset where
you're gonna give the game a chance just
because of the the record
my final thoughts is oh look everybody's
knocked it out the park I think we've
all been pretty fair as far as our
assessments and what the impact of this
game is and all the things you can do
how broad the game is and you know for
me look I'm gonna always be the hardest
on things I love and so I've always been
that way when it's something I truly
care about and I grew up with these
games these games these style games are
like the soundtrack to my gaming life
and just having the ability of sheer
scope to do anything and I have to say
you know I love this game it's very
addicting it's very when I when I knew I
cannot stop playing it and stop thinking
about it and what I'm going to do when I
come back you know that's when I knew
Starfield had it you know how a game
knows when I'm trying to sleep and I'm
thinking about what I want to do when I
get on it exactly how could I have done
that better and it's just so much to it
and look it is it perfect no and of
course there's some flaws we've all
talked about it we've all talked there's
little technical Jake here and there but
to Saul's Point yeah it is saying that
it is their most polished game
considering all the the amount that we I
would say I didn't see anything for my
first 15 hours or so I was like oh wow
this is really positive I haven't really
come across a lot of the Jane the dirty
phrase actually surprised me I thought
that would be the issue that would
bother me the most and it just it played
around and moving around and shooting
the combat it didn't fit again it was
just the consistent I didn't feel like
damn this is really sometimes it felt
like that sucker was running at like 45
frames I swear for me the only time is
where I agree with kicking is when you
go to like what I would consider the
Citadel new Atlantis you go to and then
they have the cyberpunk level of NPCs on
day night schedules and everybody's at a
place where they want to be and you got
to catch this that's what I said okay I
could see this I'm moving at 30 here and
here I'm moving 30. but when I'm doing
missions and I'm out of that particular
area I didn't I didn't feel that way so
um yeah I think this is this is going to
be the thing with this game
this is a gray gear the issue is going
to be your mileage will vary based on
your experience and what type of gamer
you are if you like a true hardcore RPG
you're gonna love this game right you're
gonna absolutely love it if you want a
more a true tutorial not in the game's
gonna hurt it too yes the onboarding
they have to do a better job to keep
that casual in because you want that
process to one too many people like five
people yes so if the the the the fault
of this game will be a casual who is
overwhelmed doesn't know all the things
he could do and let's be honest we will
say this even though we are impressed by
this game and the scope and how it looks
and everything we're not going to say
that this game is pushing the levels of
graphical Fidelity Pass Gaming this is
not that type of game I'm never gonna go
there with it so if someone's a nitpick
and be like oh we waited all this for
this and you're not understanding the
true scope it may not it may be a good
game to you or but it may not be a great
game to you but if you're a fan of
Hardcore RPGs pure scope into what attic
says best and King in the sense that
we're just used to playing Bethesda
games let's be honest
on the ground in a world when they add
this space aspect to it and you see the
depth of this space and this Frontier
and all the things you truly can do it
then almost becomes three games in one
and then it becomes how you want to play
this third aspect of the game that
literally addicted there a lot of people
you got lost in right so that's the
beauty and the last thing I want to say
is kudos to this story man kudos to this
story because I never thought that's the
last thing I said we can't talk about it
more I know because I want to just give
them their flowers this is one of the
best Main Line stories if you're a guy
that doesn't want to do that you're a
casual you do the maybe you want to
focus on that because during that period
it'll onboard you and you can really get
wrapped in yeah what they're doing and
Mrs Todd and the team's best in that
respect I would I wish I didn't expect
that from them I'm like wow I thought
this is going to be some generic yeah
get an artifact yeah whatever let me go
join this faction and do this no no no
no this is a complete game and for Xbox
look they got one they got one We're Not
Gonna Take This Moment away from them
this is this is a big game it should
drive a lot of Engagement and you know
I'm very excited by itself is worth
Bethesda yeah just listen you know this
is a game that is curious that the Game
Pass deal one dollar is over now all
right that's funny right Italian release
is very interesting shout out shout out
to Microsoft I ain't mad at you look you
know this is gonna be a game that's
going to keep people in involved for a
lot of hours and last point the future
content of what they can do with this
world and the things they can add we
already talk about you already talk
about makos we already talked about the
things you can do
with this vastness
is really going to be special and I have
I'm a guy that hasn't even done outposts
yeah it's not even deals not even DLC
see like when you think about a star
field 2 and where it
it could turn into the the biggest of
space operas ever it really could
um yeah so it's just just thinking about
where they can go is it's insane so yeah
it's to me it's it's Skyrim it's
Oblivion it's wig Commander it's it's
all these things and how you choose to
tackle it and how you choose to enjoy it
is going to be your experience but I
thoroughly enjoyed this game and shout
out to the team I think they got one
so you know I think what we're gonna do
Nick you can uh take off if you want
we're gonna just answer a couple um a
couple of these questions I we've
answered the majority of these but I do
want to answer a couple of them
all right JD I I closed the poll five
minutes ago but I'll give you your
question uh so this is from JD gamer uh
probably the most important thing is uh
is it really looking like a game of the
year or are we looking at a game of the
generation uh what do you think uh it
puts in either category so just put like
make it short because obviously if we've
been doing this for a minute it's off I
would say game of the year to start uh
I'm not far enough to see you know a lot
of the wow factor that some people are
are talking about that you guys some of
you guys have alluded to so for me I'm
enjoying it I'm enjoying the bgs-ness of
it um so it's definitely it's definitely
a game of the year Contender I don't
know beyond that but I I'm I'm enjoying
what I'm playing
King
both
okay
um I think it's going to get game of the
year and I think the tale of it the fact
that it's inside Game Pass is gonna form
a generation it's going to
this this this game draws clear battle
lines
like
either you get out and you lay down it's
just
it's it's no way about it I see people
still crying right now it's just coming
to Playstation at some point in time
no no
is God a word
no it's not so when y'all want to come
up off of Spider-Man and all that other
stuff y'all can come up off it and we'll
think about that but we
go allowing you to enjoy this one go buy
a series that's because this is game of
the generation and it's gonna be game of
the year we got D walk can you have kids
sorry all right I have it more of a game
of the year right now but I I need to
finish and do more before I make my
determination again and I agree with you
guys uh game of the year I don't know
about Game of the generation yet right I
gotta say happy battle forgive me I
gotta see how the DLC plays out too
because I feel like that always carries
over on like if this game could be a
game of generation okay got a DC walk
can you have kids I don't know do you
guys know
I just shot people I didn't try to get
some cheeks I just I just shot people I
didn't shoot my shot so
yeah I didn't I would I haven't gotten
it nor did I picked the big kids perk or
whatever it is yeah we don't we we
haven't gotten to the Buns part of the
games I mean I flirted I I flirted into
the Naughty by Nature
the hot coffee
eat all my brown what's starfield's
hardest difficulty and what is that
Force called we saw at the ending of
Starfall direct okay we can answer that
first one with that second one yeah we
can't talk about that uh so what I I
think it's just hard isn't it Starfield
yeah I mean I have it it does have a new
game plus though and it did say we were
allowed to talk about that so no we're
not allowed to talk about it no that
just that it exists that exists yeah no
that's what I meant it does have a new
game plus but we're allowed to talk
about the new game plus like that it
exists yeah uh we got Mighty Mel hello
how many Easter eggs are in the uh are
in their star foot can we expect to see
a fine Ricky and Morty is there a radio
on the cockpit oh my God I said one
uh do you have an arrow or can you can
you pet the alien Wildlife can you name
your ship can you apply uh uh yes okay
all right you went crazy
um I'm gonna pick one thing no
yeah for most of those like you can't
name your ship I don't think there's a
radio obviously you know Ricky and Morty
stuff there's no petting aiding Wildlife
there's some Wildlife that is not
aggressive somewhere life is everything
some real National Geographic Journey
you want to answer all those questions
you give a rise to the wild question
asking you get one question no rambling
entertained which is your opinion of the
best Bethesda game Studio game is up to
now me personally I'm between Morrow and
Oblivion and Skyrim New Vegas doesn't
count yet because obsidian uh Obsidian
made that I would say uh Fallout 3 is my
favorite uh well I don't know Skyrim or
they're all so good it's hard to pick
what do you just pick one
favorite one
old school or everything your favorite
Bethesda software game I'm gonna say
Skyrim
I'm gonna say Starfield okay so yeah
Starfield yeah oh yeah oh I would say
Starfield then Fallout 3.
and then
um and then Skyrim
Skyrim
but I I damn I ain't gonna lie Starfield
it's so good to be like
I feel it I just don't wanna I don't
want to speak out of turn until I gotta
finish that story I gotta finish certain
things before I but I will say it's in
that it's in that mix y'all yeah yeah so
onomatopoeia you know I I butchered this
stuff uh the Starfield hold a candle
next to Mass Effect I think starfoot has
better exploration better immersion but
not a better universe that's my opinion
what are you say King yes or no yeah I'm
sure you can answer that yes or no yes
okay
uh it's different it's different this is
about Humanity we're not seeing anything
about other racist planets or anything
of that nature so it's Starfield Mass
Effect is already in Space Opera
Starfield is kind of
the beginnings of this yes put it up
against Mass effects one yeah okay so oh
yeah I mean if you go on Mass Effect one
yeah
that's all you gotta do you can't put
three games up against one put one game
over again yeah
talk about a linear game versus an open
open open open Super open open game it
is it is it is in some ways apples to
oranges look
oh you know I'm a mass effect guys so
this is hard for me to say but it's just
two different type of games it's one is
a linear game and one between your kids
bro take between my kids yeah if it's
star field versus Mass Effect one star
field all day all right
so so this one here we've talked a lot
about her experiences between first
person and third so we're not going to
say that I want you guys to pick first
person or third
first or third
third the first one that I yeah the
first bgs game I prefer to play in third
person and if it works all the other bgs
games were frauded to me in third person
yeah this one is serviceable completely
doable and gives just one from car
hashtag just one energy in that more
that I'll give them that even though
it's not a hashtag I just want to get
you know because it starts at FPS Lucius
Augustus said Phil said that star Phil
felt more like Oblivion more like uh
Oblivion than Skyrim as a huge Elder
Scrolls dude I'm really hyped but I
enjoyed the interactive between the
systems more in Skyrim so to [__] who is
more of an oblivion guy do you know what
Phil meant by this and do you feel and
how do you feel about that do you see
the hints of Skyrim okay we will talk
about that at another time because
that's not even about star Phil like
we've been doing this too long
illustrious you know lucious that's the
homie it's more like it is more like
Oblivion but there is systems are just
so much deeper than anything in my
opinion Skyrim is doing Starfield just
has so many systems oh he was saying
what compared Oblivion or okay now I get
what he was saying yeah I agree Oblivion
I'll agree Oblivion yeah I thought he
was as good as to compare Skyrim though
oh no no no no uh solve
yeah I don't I I played Oblivion so long
ago I don't know specifically what what
feels today King wants out of here so
we're gonna move on you ain't got to go
to bed yeah no fun speculations King
just go ahead and head out man we'll
finish this there ain't that many
questions left just head out
questions pertaining to me that's true
all right let's let he here for the
marital all right Starfield is the most
important ex fun speculation star food
is the most important Xbox release since
blank
um
or you got to go through what point in
time they're at yeah coming after fumble
after fumble you're coming after uh
Master Chief not hitting critical
Acclaim you're looking at them being
third in the poll uh and they're on the
cusp of doing great stuff so you want to
build momentum
Game of the Year a game of the year game
or game of the generation game builds
that momentum this is probably the most
important game since Halo
I would say gears gears three like
airspray I would say we didn't know what
gears was
starting that's the only reason why I'm
gonna give you pushback because we know
I love how you need to go to bed but now
you good
it's just the fact that the nature of of
the question the question
where does this lie right
Microsoft needed to land Halo in order
to it to be an Xbox facts
Microsoft must land this correct if you
don't land this it's in trouble that's
it we didn't know what gears was gears
just popped out he was like oh that's a
happy surprise good point right so
it's as if if red fall would have hit a
happy surprise it's a high five Rush a
happy surprise we can go on and make
franchises out of that right so gears
two really establish that but
this game has to hit if this game
doesn't hit
it's questions in the building yeah no
I'm sorry yeah this hits this is
normally King completely I think it's
we've known about this game since 2013
as they were working on the you know
something different from Elder Scrolls
and Fallout and it it's what he said the
best King is that it had the LeBron
James effect it was supposed to be a
star before we even knew it was born so
the pressure this game had coming in was
way more immense than any other but
that's the game so for them to even
succeed and have a great game yeah I
have to say that he's right
okay for me is just it's the most
important game since the last game that
came out
and that's the thing Gamers of fickle
and have very short-term memory
um if this because this game could could
take over the world and if the next one
is mid
all of that is forgotten so and the
cycle continues so I just think
it's it the good thing is that it points
them in the right direction for
consistent quality and I just I I to me
that was the most important thing and
they nailed that because another subpar
game
back to King's Point you start
questioning things you start questioning
things does it break them completely no
no but you really really start
questioning but the hardcore are not
going to go anywhere anyway so you just
have another opportunity to try to get
it right the next time but
uh but yeah yeah it's I don't think it's
that dire but it's always good to have
great gigs okay great games great games
always help ultimate deodorant let's
let's uh uh Necromancer is there a big
difference between PC and Xbox series X
versions to play ability uh there is
obviously the 30 frames but I will say
that the Xbox version ran pretty well I
played by women I played windows and I
played uh I'm gonna be honest with you
King I'm in the attic I play both and
the jump wasn't this it wasn't this
degradation when I went down to the
x-series Exodus like I thought it would
be and I'm like oh this is I I can't
wait to try it on the on the console
because uh I like I said again on a 40
90 obviously and you play it on Steam we
got to make that yeah
something different right and I'm
playing a 30 70 on Windows play anyway
save data and I'm going back and forth
and I'm like yeah this is nice but it
ain't oh my God this is blowing away how
is the frame rate on the PC version it
was good oh
uh five thousand dollar machine up
against a 500 machine yeah it's not the
same thing paid for but are you able to
play it on the PC see you later if you
this is what you got this is what you
got okay I'll tell you right now series
action series that's performance is very
impressive on this no I I only played on
a series X and Series S and in my
opinion Series S is outpacing it because
I guess stability yes
it it's it's just what it is you
understand like maybe it's just certain
bells and whistles that I'm not seeing
that is on my my ex yeah
yeah and mind you without without do you
think on on the on the PC again being
Beastie with the settings but uh I
wasn't hitting 60 consistently yeah no
it's not it's not all right that's what
I'm hearing it like the deal there's no
DLCs so as well this is
fsr2 this is yeah to pursuitly generated
content uh it is to the game or is there
enough handcrafted content for it not to
matter so they're asking did them making
that many you know thousand planets you
know some of them are handcrafted some
of them are did that matter in the long
run to you guys I would say to a point
it did because I felt like there was a
lot of fluff in the game but that that
was intentional because you got a
universe you got to fill it out to a
degree
yeah I like I like the fluff so the
fluff works for me after a while you're
going on a planet I'm sure you love it
after a while you yeah you you love to
after a while you do see the seams
though you start to see the same type of
structures and you go in and the same
problems you start to see that on those
procedures generally planets but you
they each have their own biomes so the
weather is different stuff like that the
animals are different I don't know how
vast their library is and how they cycle
those in and out but I've seen
differences on every procedurally
General planet that I landed on except
for the the human-made structures right
yeah so um yeah for me
um it didn't bother me like I thought I
would be bothered because once King kind
of put me on to what I would call
emergent events things landing on a
planet you know Wildlife fighting each
other that I'm watching in the in the
wilderness like it's national green
graphic with the aggressive animal race
versus the past of animal race it became
no man's Sky to me so I'm like oh this
National Geographic I'm gonna stand here
and then I can get some materials but
yes I'll understand that for some people
they're not going to care about that but
for the Explorer and the guy that wants
to play that wing and get those
resources and do all that stuff it's
there for you man it's there all right
so um is it uh My Name Is Mud said is it
really as polished as people are
claiming yes it's a very polished game
there's definitely bugs but there I
didn't come across I came across one
game breaking book where I had like a
faction quiz that kind of malfunctioned
a little bit but besides that
in a big game like this the only real
big things I had was like I would have
to reload a save because you know I got
locked into something or you know
someone's face disappeared and there's
only eyeballs like that's all and we're
talking we're taking we're talking about
65 which Assassin's Creed but we're
talking about 65 hours of game play and
that's all I came across yeah I'm on the
on Steam like I said before I had about
25 crashes to desktop in 75 hours
in 75 in 75 hours but again
I don't know if uh King's talking about
this next question from mayo5 can I walk
in the line uh can I walk in a straight
line more than 6 40 minutes
talking about coming out boundaries look
man everything got boundaries every
PlayStation every Xbox game nothing is
Limitless it's not Minecraft
isn't even Limitless there's still an
end
I'm not gonna sit here because I saw
some some stupid narrative online yeah I
don't know
I don't do you walk the earth
have you have how many hours would it
take for you to walk from New York to
California you let me know how many days
it's gonna get there and you let me know
if this is a boundary to your legs if
they pop off
so idiotic with a lot of stuff it's
invisible walls walk from here and I'm
I'ma time you walk from New York from
where I'm at to California E3 y'all get
out of here
you're gonna get tired of walking long
before yeah
that's hilarious the irony of this
quote-unquote criticism is these are the
same people who didn't want procedural
generated planets these are the same
people who didn't want any of that type
of it's fluff I what were five but now
they want to sit there and walk from New
York to California and mad that there
may be an invisible wall in Montana like
come on like what are we doing and then
the last thing I want to say is they
give you like multiple spots to land on
the planet and they pick like this
that's another thing
you can pick your own spot to land on
the planet 100
so tell me I'm just sick and tired of
these dudes talking about they cannot
walk from here to there you don't do it
anyway
so we got Stitch asking uh
could the game benefit from 60 frames or
is 30 frames good enough obviously it
can benefit from 60 frames I think
everything can benefit from 60 uh a
solid 30 and again I want to experience
it on the console I haven't yet yet but
uh like I said on on the PC it wasn't
really sticking to 60 without help so um
yeah but 60 is nice all right so of
course 60 is nice so Eden Haynes says
how does uh the story aiding is it to
fly in space being in space was the
worst part of No Man's Sky did Bethesda
do a better job oh no let me jump in
this is the best all that space is so
good once you just get over that you
gotta flip the switches and you want to
bring you want to bring engine up bring
your lasers up bring you oh and don't do
it in the car trying to run from people
acceleration and not accelerate and
don't do the Cog where you don't have no
meter on grab jump and you try to get
out of town
jump into the next type of space
[Music]
don't think that you're gonna you're
gonna bypass this title by playing no
man's Sky yeah all right just don't no
no no not at all different experiences
like I said I I for me is the fluidity
of the you know fly up in space whatever
I wish this title would have that but
again it's still they're two different
products yeah it's it's just it's just
me wanting like everything everybody's
games all together all together but we
we gonna give Starfield that ship combat
yeah we're gonna get that there ain't
nobody rocking with them one I this is
Win command and server this is that
that's what I was looking for yeah you
know we're gonna get them they flowers
so lionmaster said how is the
conversation system compared to previous
Bethesda games we pretty much answered
that it's it's yeah it's it's it's more
robust uh the the voice acting is very
very good excellent especially big main
story stuff but even side stuff man the
voice acting is really good and really
good then we got taper he says uh ship
and based building looks kind of tedious
will I be missing out if I skip on those
things I have really not built too many
ships I haven't done nothing on Base
building I've just added on to ships
like you know add like another Wing so I
could put more guns uh for the most part
that's all that I haven't touched to
that degree and I've still got 60 70
hours in the game so I think you're good
yeah I think in-game stuff is there I I
personally am going to do more ship
building because I want to have a
research station and all that stuff on
the ship to do so I don't have to go
okay he's laughing and The Outpost stuff
I feel is like in game but yeah it's
there for you but you don't have to do
none of that yeah
black girl and can I traffic drugs to
the Galaxy communities and will my
parents approve okay so this is where
we're done at and y'all just win
questions you know I got to get up a
little work yeah Contraband is in the
game and let's get your own record all
right let me get these two patreon
questions because we did not answer one
I would just answer part of this uh good
evening Lords cheers to you all look
forward to everyone having a stellar
time uh uh type of time what did they
have a game of the year what are the
chances uh what is the neighborhood gave
everyone the chance to be a clown our
black hole I didn't encounter a black
hole the whole time I played I don't
know about you guys sidebar how or bad
or the Zone haters are tweeting about
out AKA The Invisible wall well he
literally just talked about that uh so
we could just move past on that um okay
what was the next last question uh good
evening all I know the game is going to
be great my question to everyone is what
is the one mod you want to see in the
game for me I would want a Halo ring ooh
a quest on it it would uh continue the
Halo story long shot but could happen I
would say Mars they're definitely
putting a Hillary in this guy like yeah
mods are going to make this game uh
extra special but for me
go over so I can drive from here to
California
and hit that wall and hit the wall
obliterate your fake walls that y'all
putting up so that that's where we're
ending this man we went over three hours
how we do an IOP just for Starfield no
we're not doing this no more
let me tell you I was really nice
tonight
yeah so shout out to King thanks
Bethesda for the code that's what I was
literally about to do I want to thank
Bethesda personally you was able to let
us all have a conversation and we really
ain't never done that before yes you
know we will have to start pushing for
that more often uh you know I think we
think we all really enjoy it no I I'm
gonna I'm Gonna Be Strong arming these
no I
buddy well maybe we edit this part out
of this but we added that part but
nothing but but listen
um just a tip for everyone say
frequently use that quick use that quick
say
sorry once again shout out to Bethesda
for all for uh for providing all four of
us a code we will see there will be no
IOP the week that you get this because
we will be in Pax West but when we come
back we're gonna we plan a pretty
Stella show for the the Metacritic
scores of uh start field but I
appreciate it for coming through uh Cog
and solve and King you guys got anything
to say are we just gonna click the
record button look thank you for the
opportunity but that's the again we
can't wait for everyone to get their
hands on it uh listen to our Impressions
see if they agree or disagree this is
one of those definitely one of those
games one of those those Zeitgeist
moments that everyone should be a part
of and I'm looking forward to the
discussion I think this is this is great
it's good to be back with my brothers
and it feels good just talking games
again but uh again start oh shout out to
Todd Howard shout out to the entire team
you can see the yeah you can see the
labor of love you can see for the
hardcore RPG lover you know the person
who truly wants to see the great
Frontier there's a lot of stuff here and
um can't wait for everyone to to get
their hands with the game and then
presses in the Xbox you know again
salute this was I see why he went for
the acquisition and these are the type
of games those are those generational
type games that we will continue to talk
about and these are the games that I
love these are the type of games I love
the most so salute and uh solve King
y'all got the final thoughts yeah shout
out to Bethesda for for uh providing the
codes and allowing us to talk about it
as a team
um again I I just love the fact that all
these different perspectives at the same
time think it's a unique way to talk
about you know and kind of review a game
so uh thank you for that and yeah I'm
excited for everybody to get their hands
on it because this is a game where I'm
excited everybody's story is going to be
different words
everybody's story is different right
everybody's experience is going to be
different and uh that's just exciting
around a game like this so I I'm super
super amped just for day one to see the
excitement for people to have it um yeah
so I think thank you again
King
thank you Bethesda for making him an NDA
dude boy
I'm down
um yeah normally I don't get a chance to
be up late night doing this stuff
usually I'm in my bed sleep
um well these guys is all willy-nilly
not me this is new for me too well
usually it's be an addict yeah but we
appreciate both of you I get to say this
um
this is the inflection point this is the
point where you have to sit down you're
going to look at your console and you're
going to actually console if it's
performing
this is it this is this is the moments
that you have if you're going to jump
ship if you're going to come on over
because the water's fine
this is game media type stuff
uh the grass is indeed generation
greener on the other side
game of the generation that's left to be
determined
uh but as far as this year goes
hands down
better than anything I've played so far
this year and I'm talking about RPGs to
anything else that I've played
this is a monster this is a beast if
it's is it a graphical Powerhouse
when you take in totality what it's
doing
it's an animal
that you just can't contain so
um thank you Bethesda I cannot wait to
see what people say when they get this
game in their hands and get a chance to
talk about the story later on when we're
not under embargo and we can talk about
fractions and stuff like that uh we did
a hard three hours pulse
um
three and a half for this game I will
gladly you know stay up and talk about
this because I think this game we put 65
plus a lot of us did so three hours to
talk about it seems about right yeah
and like I said appreciate uh the review
code you know it meant the most to me
that we could all experience at the same
time uh yeah yeah and uh we have more
coverage for you guys you know Cog and
solving King doing some stuff here soon
so uh oh yeah appreciate it everyone and
we're gonna close out